Five,
four,
three,
two.
The infamous Jamie countdown our
lifetime.
What is up man?
Tom Bilyeu.
If you're wondering,
Bill,
you believe people are wondering like,
how do I say that pill?
You Dude,
I've eaten more of your bars than any
bar ever in the history of bars next to
you in the primal kitchen bars.
Whoa,
that's it.
You're in fucking La Company there,
man.
That's God.
Goddamn quest bars.
The Shit.
Especially those chocolate Brownie ones.
Dude,
tell me about it.
Guys.
Nailed it with those.
Thank you.
So what was the idea behind the company
is like some low sugar,
low carb Nutricia and yet at the time
that we were thinking of launching the
company,
there was nothing on the market that we
would eat at either tasted terribly and
was good for you or it tasted great and
was horrible for you.
So we wanted to create the first bar
that tasted like it had sugar but
didn't.
And metabolically speaking had a great
response to it.
It's a grind man to find.
If you try to go on a Keto Diet and you
know,
you try to find like really good,
healthy,
delicious stuff to snack on,
like boy,
here's a question.
Two quest bars kick you out of Ketosis.
No,
really know if I eat a full bar,
I'm going to be out.
Really?
Sure.
But it only has nine grams of carbs.
Grams of protein is high,
so it.
Well,
it's actually less than that depending.
Do you count net carbs or full blown?
You know what?
I'm very loose with it.
I don't do a whole lot of counting
carbs.
For the most part.
What I'm doing is eating whole foods.
The most part I'm doing is a lot of,
a lot of that primal kitchen.
You know that pole lay Mayo,
that aaa lime,
Mayo Bullshit.
Fucking fantastic.
I might eat a case of that a month and
I'm not bullshitting.
I put it on everything because it's
super high fat and really delicious.
So I put it on eggs.
I go cook up a couple of eggs in the
morning and then I'll take some scoops
so that chipotle a line male and just
slap it on there with sliced Jalapenos
and so we get a lot of facts.
You know the macros on it?
No,
I don't talk to that.
All that shit.
But you stay in Ketosis,
you can take your blood levels have.
Yeah,
I have do it on a regular basis.
I just essentially eat.
I,
well what I'm doing is for the most
part,
if I'm eating foods,
the foods that I'm eating are very high
fat,
very low carbs and then 20 percent of
the time I fuck off 20 percent of the
time,
like 20 percent into like I try not to
fuck off too hard.
Like with desserts and stuff like that.
Do you like desserts?
Yes.
Even on a Keto Diet,
you don't find that that's reduced?
Yeah,
it is reduced,
but once you start eating the ice cream,
you remember how awesome it is?
Yeah.
But a lot,
a lot exoticness ketones don't fuck with
never done ever exhaust.
Ah,
did I try it once?
I think I did,
I was told that it would like help with
the headache and I was like,
I call bullshit.
Oh,
okay.
For like the Keto flu.
Uh,
it wasn't when I had,
I did have keto flu profoundly.
Uh,
but that's what happens when you're a
dumb ass the first time that you try
going ketogenic.
How did you,
uh,
what'd you do?
I went true four to one after a three
day.
Fast forward to one.
Explain that to people.
So for every gram of combined protein
and carbohydrate,
I ate.
I ate four grams of fat,
which is brutally difficult to do.
You never going to do it by accident.
I had a spreadsheet and everything that
I ate had to go through the math.
So I had to figure out like,
what's this going to be as a total meal?
Uh,
you,
you literally have to like scrape every
bit of oil out of the pan.
Like you've got to be hardcore sop up.
Like if you've got cabbage or something,
sop up all the oil to make sure that
you're getting it all.
It was hateful.
I absolutely hated.
It was so disgusting and dom has talked
about that.
The palatability afforded one is very,
very low at the time I thought I needed
to do that.
I was trying to do cancer prevention.
Uh,
so I went hard hardcore Quito trying to
get the ratio between my blood glucose
and my ketones.
Right.
Were you experiencing health
difficulties?
Uh,
no.
So,
but at quest we were really trying to
like experiment,
like find out what's the edge of this
stuff.
We were putting millions of dollars into
research,
especially into cancer.
I'm trying to find out like,
does a ketogenic diet have the positive
implications on cancer that we hope it
does?
And um,
at least in a clip that I saw on your
show when dom was on,
he was talking about that the,
um,
the enter the energy crisis that the
cells go through that are cancerous
because some forms of cancer.
Yeah,
there's,
there's some funny thing.
It's all of them.
I know some people are.
There was an article recently about
brain cancer.
There was a type of brain cancer that
actually lived off of fat,
um,
that didn't respond to a low carb diet.
I mean,
I believe there's several different
kinds of cancer and so I don't know if
all the data's in on that.
Right.
So your idea was just to do it just to
get yourself in a really healthy state
and monitor your own.
Yeah.
My thing was like if,
if it has that potential,
it's worth trying.
Right.
What's the three day fast,
not a big deal.
And then two weeks of being in Ketosis,
going into it.
I didn't know how hard it was going to
be.
I didn't know what four to one was going
to feel like and I didn't know how to
supplement.
So it was,
it was real misery and I really did have
what they call the Keto flu.
You feel like you have the flu.
It's sucked.
And my whole thing is like being uber
discipline.
So once I commit to something,
I'm not going to stop just because it
sucks and I wasn't smart enough to go
and ask somebody.
Like,
what do you do?
is there a way to supplement your way
out of this?
Uh,
so I just muscled through,
but it was total misery.
Find it.
I don't understand why you never tried
exogenous ketones.
That doesn't make a lot of sales.
So,
you know Peter Attia,
right?
No,
you don't know Peter Attia.
Who is it?
You have to immediately get them on your
show.
So Peter Attia is a good friend of
dominic d'agostino.
So that would be an easy connect.
And he's a doctor,
a physician.
Um,
he did a ted talk which crushed
absolutely amazing.
And he goes from practicing traditional
medicine.
And this is his ted talks.
This isn't me,
this is him saying it being fairly
judgmental about the people that just
treating this woman comes in,
she has diabetes and um,
Oh God,
I think she was either there to have an
amputation or she'd already had won
something.
Anyway,
he realizes and as he starts all this
down to this is like a human being and
he,
what they're doing isn't solving the
problem.
So he's like somewhere the system is
failing a lot of people and how do we
rectify it?
And,
and as he's giving the Ted talk,
he starts like crying is so amazing,
especially getting to know him and
knowing that it's totally sincere.
This is not a guy faking it for the
camera and so ends up completely
changing his life.
He starts,
I'm really trying to figure out what's
going on.
Metabolically finds high-fat finds
ketogenics for awhile was known as the
the fat man or the Quito man.
I forget what they call them,
but long before I'd ever heard of
ketogenics and starts new,
see you heard a new nutritional science
initiative raises a ton of money and
they're trying to do like real
double-blind empirical studies on
nutrition because they're like,
eh,
like there's so much guesswork in all of
this.
We really want to prove it ends up
leaving that.
I don't,
I won't speak to why I honestly don't
know,
but ends up leaving new.
See I'm founding a private practice as
like a high end concierge guy.
We were trying to get them involved at
quest just because his,
nutritionally this guy's mind is unreal.
And so talking to him about that stuff
and him walking us through like Keto flu
and how you can actually supplement your
way out of it and all that.
But I unfortunately didn't know it at
the time.
Uh,
so yeah,
I suffered needlessly.
So,
um,
that's the flu thing is a weird feeling,
right?
Because your body just feels so weak and
you don't understand it.
You'd be eating and you,
you almost learned denial.
Like I can't believe that this is just
carbs.
There's no way.
Like this is something something's going
on.
Is it carves or is it protein?
I mean I guess gluconeogenesis is
turning the protein into glucose but it
is weird.
Or is it that and this.
I actually don't know the answer to and
that.
And I'm now outside my realm of what I
understand.
So full disclosure,
but there's obviously something in the
micro nutrients because the people that
later told me you could have
supplemented your way out of this.
They were talking about,
and I don't remember well,
but it was like magnesium and some other
things.
It wasn't,
oh,
just,
you know,
have more carbs or more protein,
but I will say at a two to one diet you
at least I didn't experience the flu at
all and that was sustainable and I did
that for nine months and that was
amazing.
It was transformative from an anti
inflammatory perspective is just
unbelievable.
So just more low carb than Quito total.
So I've been low carb for a very long
time because I,
if I am having a cheat weekend and you
were talking about this just before we
went live,
if I'm having a cheat way can be raw.
You can hear me getting fatter.
Like it is so crazy how well my body
turns a calorie into adipose tissue.
It's nuts.
So fatter.
Quicker.
I get fat very,
very fast,
especially with carbohydrate.
Um,
but even if I spiked my calories and
they're all clean,
I'll get fat fast.
Wow.
And this didn't used to be the case
before you tried these low carb diets.
Now this is always the case always.
Oh,
so yeah,
it wasn't until.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's why I tried low carb.
So I'm so frustrated with always being
like having a wet look,
a wet look.
What's that?
Uh,
maybe I'm making that up.
So that's what my partners and I used to
refer to people like me who just have a
natural smooth layer of fat,
like I have to,
I have to do so much cardio to get that
like dry look where you just really
tight,
like a massive amount of cardio.
And is that the case even with a,
like a low carb diet,
like when you get to lean on a low carb
diet to be sure,
but it doesn't.
Like if I want to be lean,
lean,
I have to do cardio.
So you're essentially got a really good
adaptation body for famine,
yell,
I'll survive a famine.
The Zombie apocalypse.
I've got you.
Like I'm making it through that.
Very confident.
Do you watch walking dead?
Because a lot of people that think
they're gonna make it.
They don't make them in a way behind.
I'm on like seasoned.
Where'd you stop?
Because people are telling me I'm going
to jump on when they killed Glen.
Oh Wow.
It's a spoiler alert.
I guess,
right?
Uh,
I made it that far.
I made it that far,
but yeah,
now we're beyond that.
So.
But here's what I find interesting about
that is I want to do like some content
on what are,
like the 10 leadership lessons you can
learn from the walking dead because I
think they're,
they're like,
that's what I find interesting about the
show.
Rick is inconsistent.
I'm not buying them in this last season.
That's why I bailed out.
I don't know man.
I mean,
what,
what leadership thinks you're going to
learn when everyone's turned to shit and
a bunch of people killing each other.
All right,
so let's go to one that you would have
seen because before Glenn dies,
you've got the kid,
they find them at the bar,
the guy,
his team mates,
I don't have a better word for that is
clan.
Whatever.
They go ballistic.
They start shooting.
You take back to your place and you want
to help him.
He failed his leg.
He's hurt.
Do you kill them?
Do you set them free?
What do you do?
A Web TV show.
It's not real.
You have to be a really around the guy.
You'd have to know.
Right.
You know,
I think it's part logic and part
instinct when you're dealing with a
situation like that,
like how much of this guy's behavior was
because he was stuck with a bunch of
other shitty people and how different is
he when he's free and how much does he
listen to reason and logic and how much
is he willing to contemplate the
possibility that there's a better life.
Everybody works together.
If not kill them.
You don't want.
If you think that he's imaginably
damaged,
like maybe he's a big liar,
he lies about a lot of stuff and you
know,
you can't count on him.
You know he's going to be a liability
and he's not going to be an asset and he
might very well tried to kill you in
your sleep or something like that.
Yeah.
You got to kill him.
Right?
Yeah.
That's what I find interesting about the
show is that it makes you think about
stuff like that.
Let me ask you this.
If something does happen,
like asteroidal impact,
right?
And there's only like 10 percent of the
people left.
Do you want to be amongst those 10
percent of the people or would you
rather be one of the people that died?
Wow,
that seems like a trick question.
I want to be one of the 10 percent.
Like,
can I just say,
have you read the stand by?
No,
no dude,
you would love it.
Yeah.
So it's about your super flew,
right?
So wipes out,
let's say it's 10 percent.
I don't remember what the number is,
but it wipes out virtually everybody.
And then the remaining people have the
task of rebuilding society analysis,
Stephen King novels.
So there's a lot of weird shit going on.
But that captured my imagination so
profoundly when I read it,
I read it probably 15 years old,
dude.
I still think about that.
I think that would,
while I wouldn't want it,
because inevitably a lot of people that
you love end up being in the 90 percent
us,
so that would suck.
Um,
but if it happened it would be
fascinating to see how we rebuild.
But if you've seen the road,
that's a pretty dark take on what
happens.
But yeah,
I'm a little more optimistically.
I mean,
look,
it could be wonderful if you really can
survive and you really find a way to
live off the land and you find a good
group of people and you all work in
coordination and he cooperate and you
have a wonderful little civilization.
Take care of each other or if you get
horribly ugly and then you could be
dealing with the cannibals and marauders
and people invading you and where,
where do you fall?
But what do you mean 90 percent?
Ten percent.
Oh,
100 percent or 90 percent really.
I mean,
they have with that rock.
Wow.
I'll call this dude.
That's interesting.
And you don't want to be one of those
survivors when there's nothing left.
You know,
you don't want to be dealing with people
seeing if you can eat it.
Charred foot,
you know,
because you're super starving.
Well,
put,
just,
um,
I mean,
maybe it's a copout look,
the only reason why we're here is
because monkeys fucked when they were
living in trees,
you know?
And they figured out a way to get to
become a person over who knows how many
millions of generations or whatever it's
been.
But I think if you really stop and think
about what your life would be,
if everybody out there was dead and
there was only like 10 percent of people
that first of all,
90 percent of the people dead.
That's a lot of stinking rotten bodies.
You've got to get through that.
How it's going to be awful.
There's going to be 10 percent.
What's the odds that any fuckers know
how to work electricity or know how to
get a generator going or know how to re
up a power plant.
Like what if a power plant goes down?
What if uh,
the grid is down,
you need to fix a car.
Do you even understand how a car works?
Like most people don't?
Ten percent.
If you could get really unlucky and get
10 percent of the people who don't know
shit and they're just looking for a job.
Yup.
Those are the people that survive.
No question.
If that's the case,
you might not make it.
Do you know the,
the united,
the United States,
but the human population got down to a
thing they think is low as like,
I want to say 7,000
people at one point in time after the
eruption of a or something like the
Super Volcano.
Yeah.
There was some super volcano eruption
that.
There's a theory that it dropped the
human population down to an unbelievably
low level and it was not that long ago
either.
I think it was like 60,000
years ago or something like that.
Well,
I didn't know that.
The timing,
but yeah,
I had heard that,
which is pretty fascinating.
Not Good.
Not good if that's real 60,000
years ago.
Especially when you think of genetic
diversity.
That's really terrifying.
Yeah.
Maybe that accounts for a lot of our
fuckups,
you know,
it's interesting too.
And they also,
they keep finding these new humans,
you know,
like fossilized.
You're talking about.
Yeah,
like new humans that they didn't know
existed.
Like they found one in Russia fairly
recently,
like an offshoot of humans.
Like we just Kinda got lucky to make it
to this that,
you know,
not read Homo Deus.
No.
So Noah,
you've all Harare also wrote sapiens.
He talks about that sort of thing in
both of his books.
Like how is it luck?
What do we have?
Like what made humans the Apex Predator
and looking at,
you know,
our ability to be social.
But where does that come from?
Like when you look at.
So the way that he ended up defining it
is the reasons that humans become the
apex Predator is because unlike an ant,
which is actually very,
very impressive with how they can
organize large number of hands beings,
whatever you were classified as,
um,
they can't do it flexibly.
So it's like we have sort of a pre
written code and these are the things
that we do and that's it.
And you fall in the line,
you go to food like you build the
colonies is always the same way humans
can organize and similarly large
numbers,
but they can do it flexibly.
So you can organize and watch a nascar
race.
You can organize and fight a war.
You can organize and build a church like
whatever the ways that we want to
organize and one of the things he says
is at the heart of that is our ability
to convey um,
kinship through something other than
genetic relations.
So,
um,
what he refers to it as is like that,
the grand fiction,
the narrative that we tell each other,
which is often religion or whatever,
but it lets people who've never met
like,
uh,
the way I always like to think of it.
Imagine two guys that meet each other
and they both ride Harley's never ever
met,
but they click right because they share
that thing which is a stand in for a
belief system.
So that to me is pretty interesting as
to whether like,
and,
and his hypothesis is the reason that we
ended up taking over neanderthals and
all that was because because of that,
because we could organize using
symbology using metaphor,
we were able to organize more flexibly
in larger numbers and really be accurate
with how to attack and things like that
so that we could eliminate to rival
clan.
Oh,
totally makes sense.
I mean,
that's a,
it's one of the more fascinating aspects
of being a person,
right?
So we can assume so many different
forms,
culture and behavior and the patterns
that we follow.
But you gotta think if we got down with
7,000
people,
we're pretty lucky.
Pretty lucky.
If that was,
wasn't like a full wipe out.
I'm fucking terrified of yellowstone.
Well,
that's one of those,
as you look closely at it as like a.
I just pretend that that's not a threat.
I don't know what else to do.
There's nothing you can do,
but if it's.
If it goes,
it's a global one.
Look,
it's a real problem globally.
I mean it's locally,
it's a disaster,
but globally it's,
it's a real problem.
It's going to cloud the skies,
it's going to put us into a nuclear
winter.
Those,
those big ones like the one that they
think.
See,
did you find anything on that one?
What we.
Where was it a say?
Indonesia.
South Asia.
Yeah.
Something crazier on it too.
It said there's a couple of studies at
how many people were left and instead
there was roughly maybe a thousand
reproductive adults,
some as low as 40 reproductive pairs,
which it'd be like 80 people still be
kids maybe,
but that's,
that's rough.
And the amount of Jesus Christ,
most likely there was a drastic dip.
And then 5,000
to 10,000
bedraggled homosapien struggled together
for a pitiful little clumps hunting and
gathering for thousands of years until
the late stone age.
Wow.
When we humans began to recover.
Holy Fuck.
But it was a time.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Um,
we didn't.
Damn near went extinct.
Wow.
So yes.
Seventy thousand BC.
So a little bit more than 70,000
years ago.
A volcano.
Hold on,
hold on.
A called Toba in Sumatra or in
Indonesia?
Went off blowing roughly 650 miles of
vaporized rock into the air.
It's the largest volcanic eruption we
know of.
Dwarfing.
Everything else.
Holy Shit,
man.
That's comparison to.
Wow,
that's interesting to see that you see
Mount Saint Helens,
the amount of ejected material versus.
Wow.
So,
so it got down to as low as 40 mating
pairs.
Studies suggest that?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
I mean we're just at the whim of the
natural forces that make mountains and
there's a giant volcano called Dara
volcano under yellowstone and I think
like a week ago they had something like
1500 earthquakes wasn't like some,
some she's taken like a month and a
month period of time.
They,
they,
it was like really recently they talked
about this,
how many earthquakes they had over a
very short period of time.
That just constant and consistent.
Just crazy in June.
It's at 400.
Okay.
There was something in,
uh,
I believe it was in July.
It was another one like really recently.
But you know,
that just that kind of shit that there
can be 400 earthquakes and a month like
what?
Eight hundred and 78 weeks later.
That's it.
That's the thing.
I was looking at 878 earthquakes in two
weeks.
Does what it was.
So it's like 1200 plus earthquakes in a
month and two weeks for four.
And that's not much small earthquake.
But it's the idea that there are so
significant volcanic activity under
something that we didn't even know was a
volcano until like,
I want to say like a decade or two ago,
they use satellite imagery to figure it
out that it was called Dara.
They didn't even know it is that you
can,
you can't see it until you get far
enough up that you really started to see
greater.
That's what's nuts.
Yeah.
They realized what it is.
It must've been like a horror movie when
they pulled back and went,
oh my God,
Oh my God.
It's like that scene in a twilight zone
and to serve man.
It's a cookbook.
I haven't seen that.
Never seen that one.
A precious few,
um,
twilight zones to be honest,
to serve.
It's one of the best ones.
Yeah.
It's a bunch of aliens.
Come down here.
Spoiler alert for 1950 bucks.
But they come down here and they realize
that they,
they,
somewhere along the line people realize
that there's something going on and that
they're taking these people board their
spaceship and they're not coming back.
And then at the end they've left this
book and the book they thought to serve,
man,
God was like they wanted to serve us.
It turns out it's a cookbook,
but too late,
they're already bored spaceship ready to
get eaten.
It's dope to the twilight zone.
Has some awesome endings.
I have to give it that.
Well,
they had such a bounty of premises.
The premises are incredible.
Only to this day,
if you stop and think about all the,
you remember William Shatner with the
agility that the.
See that one where there was like a,
I think I've seen like three and I don't
remember them.
He went to a diner and there was a place
that he,
uh,
was at that had like one of those
little,
um,
like a fortune teller box.
It was like these tabs jukeboxes that
were in d.
do you ever see a jukebox in a diner?
Yeah.
So like you'd be sitting at a table and
you can actually control the music.
This thing that you're seeing up there,
he had a fortune teller and you would
put in a cent or one cent coin and ask
him a question,
yes or no question.
It would give you answers and he became
obsessed with it.
I started started fucking with them and
it was like it was getting too close to
reality as I say.
Is it coming true?
Like is he.
Yeah.
I don't want to give away any spoilers,
but it was just a great show man.
I mean just they tried to bring it back.
Right,
but I think it tanked.
Wouldn't they try to bring it back?
God,
I want to say early nineties that I can
be way off on the date,
but was that.
They definitely tried to bring it back
without rod sterling.
It's going to be tough and I wonder how
many of them were actually written by
Rod Sterling.
A good question because he was always a
host of it.
Imagine if he was just a host and it
really didn't have nothing to do with
it.
I brought it back in the eighties and
nineties.
Really?
Yeah.
It's hard when you get something like
that,
first of all,
you've got to pay a lot for it because I
know that was one of the reasons why
they switched over the tower of terror
ride at Disneyland to guardians of the
galaxy was that they couldn't come to a
licensing agreement with the twilight
zone.
Really?
Yeah.
Because the tower of terror ride was
always about the twilight zone with rod
sterling would come out in the beginning
of it and that was the whole.
The whole ride was about this haunted
tower,
you know,
when you get into it and it just takes
you to this crazy fucking ride and they
somehow or another couldn't come to some
sort of a deal.
So they decided to turn it into the
guardians of the galaxy.
Rod Seems,
uh,
if you have a deal with Disney,
you know,
seems like you'd want to keep that rock
and roll.
Keep that dude.
Somebody's got greedy.
I would agree with that.
That's a big part of business,
isn't it?
Somebody just gets a little crazy.
It was a little too much.
Adderall fits a little fired up.
It gets cocky.
Yeah,
you'd be surprised how often that
happens behind doors.
Entrepreneurship
is,
it gets weird.
It's like you were,
you just dealing with,
going back to your point about these are
monkeys that learned how to have sex and
then do something,
uh,
you feel that sometimes.
Also I would imagine being an
entrepreneur,
like organizing a team of people that
are going to work together in harmony
and not stab each other in the back,
not trip each other up with office
politics,
not getting away with a bunch of
bullshit social issues between each
other.
Like how do you structure that?
Like,
I mean I can't imagine what it'd be like
to run a significant business and have a
lot of it being dependent upon the way
that people in the office that you don't
even know.
Yes.
Hire them the way they interact with
each other.
Yeah.
So one,
you have to get really good at thin
slicing people.
You have to be able to very rapidly
identify like are these going to be
people that are gonna make this a better
place to work?
Which is one of the things that I think
is most important,
like,
forget or they go to their job that's
important to you,
got to know that,
but are they going to make this a better
place to work?
And some of the biggest mistakes I made
in my career have been keeping people
because they were good at their job even
though they were toxic to the
environment,
walking dead type scenario,
coming back and telling you like there
are any other lessons that you can learn
about entrepreneurship and stuff like
that where it from pop culture.
So yeah,
that,
that would be one of them.
That was really intense.
Uh,
figuring that one out.
That was a hard lesson.
And then knowing when your businesses
transition.
So in the beginning you're a startup,
nobody knows who you are,
you don't have enough revenue.
So you need people that are going to
just bust ass.
They're gonna come in,
they're going to be hardcore hustlers,
get it done.
Whatever it takes.
Two am on a Friday,
they are going to be there for you.
But then at some point,
and the reason by the way that you're,
that you can make that exchange is you
can't pay them a lot.
They don't have a lot of skills.
So what they have to offer is they're
willing to work hard.
So you're essentially throwing human
capital at whatever problems you have.
Now,
if you get the right people motivated
and you're a lead from the front kind of
guy.
Like when we first started quest,
I was wearing a hairnet everyday lab
coat.
I was making protein bars,
but I would walk in and say what's the
worst job?
And whatever.
The Guy said,
this is the worst job today.
It's a little sticky,
whatever.
So this station is actually the worst.
So I would take that station and I would
rock it with a smile on my face.
I will be upbeat,
energetic,
and I would just outwork everybody.
And the reason I did that was I knew
when the day came that it was going to
be a Friday at 2:00
AM and they're all gonna want to go home
and.
But we've got to get this batch done
that no one would ever question my work
ethic.
So when I said,
guys,
I need you to stay,
like they would be there.
Um,
also because of where we were when
you're in manufacturing,
you're inevitably in the inner cities,
the only place you can afford that kind
of real estate.
So we were hiring from the surrounding
neighborhoods.
So we're literally in Compton hiring
people that grew up in the inner cities
hardcore.
And I remember my first lesson in hope
and one of the guys came up to me was
just killing himself.
He's doing such an amazing job and just
always working,
putting in the hours,
doing whatever it takes.
And he came up to me one day and he
said,
you know,
you care more about my success in my own
mother.
And he was like,
I never had a vision of my future.
I didn't want to look at it.
It was because his sister had been shot
to death in the heart with an AK 47 in
his front yard when she was like 12.
So it,
it's just,
there's so many stories like that you
can imagine.
Another guy held his father while he
bled to death from a gunshot wound to
the head.
I mean,
just nuts.
And so hearing him say that,
I was like,
he was saying it as a way to explain why
he was so committed,
why he was working so hard because
basically he didn't use these words,
but basically I've never had hope before
and this is really fucking exciting.
So.
But then understanding where does that
transition,
right?
Where do you go from,
okay,
I need a bunch of hustlers.
We don't have the money to throw at
really skilled labor,
so I need to throw it at people that'll
just work really,
really hard.
But then at some point it's what I call
the dragon begins to eat its own tail.
So you're growing so fast,
you're getting so big that without the
systems,
without professional management in place
like you,
you just can't get bigger because people
start stepping on each other's toes.
It starts getting confusing.
The leadership isn't close enough to
everybody that that sort of do or
diamond tells you that they would see in
me.
They would see me on the line,
they would see how I would work.
It's not there anymore.
Right?
So now there's layers between you and it
started to fall apart that that was a
hard lesson.
So realizing that,
Whoa,
like I've got to now start bringing in
professional managers actually know what
they're doing that have done this
before,
built out production studios or
manufacturing so that we can really do
it right.
That we can put systems in place to take
care of people.
But then you get bureaucracy which is
like a nightmare,
especially for the hustlers.
So then they feel disenfranchised,
but it's the only way for you to grow
and how do you deal with all of that
shit.
So yeah,
it is weird.
I've got to imagine also like you want
the people that are working for you to
have some sort of a stake in the success
of the business.
So like organizing that.
It's got to be difficult.
Like how much of a percentage of the
business do you give to the workers?
Like you have to make to incentivize
them to like really innovate and there's
got to be something on the line for
them.
They would.
There was something,
some sort of reward I would imagine.
Right.
Will you be shocked how many people
don't agree with that?
Now I'm with you and to me it's.
And I guess it's what's the argument
against it that you're not gonna get
anything for it,
that it's nice in idea,
but they won't actually work harder.
They won't work smarter.
They just.
They're not in a position to bring
benefit from getting that,
but here's what all this is the argument
I've always given to people that say
that it you're not going to get the
benefit from them maybe that you would
get from you.
Like I get equity is triggering you in a
certain way and you've got a certain
skillset and so you can execute against
that,
but especially now from millennials down
the sense of working for the man,
working for some other.
Like there's no stability in that
equation anymore.
You used to trade 40 years of your life
because you could just kind of count on
the fact that you would be there for 40
years.
Those days are gone,
man.
People spend something like one point
eight years or something at a given job
and then they move on the best way to
get a raise as the jumped to another
company.
So millennials do they jump around
around,
around.
So there's no longer this like,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm going to give you stability and
you're going to give me like,
uh,
an adequate level of performance.
So those days are gone.
Now.
My thing with ownership is one,
tie it to being there until an exit.
So that what I'm trying to incentivize
as you taking me all the way across the
finish line,
so if you don't take me across the
you don't get anything.
Fair enough.
And then on top of that,
just the sense of really being able to
say I own a piece of this company is so
empowering for people,
especially for people for whom that's
never been an option.
Maybe it was never an option for their
parents like they,
they've never even heard of a company
doing something like that.
Being able to go to literally the lowest
person on the totem pole and say,
I'm going to give you,
it's going to be small obviously,
but I'm going to give you some
percentage ownership in this company and
now literally we're all owners.
So you have like the most selfish
incentive to make this company
successful.
Ever.
Now where this gets tricky.
Can I ask you to go to stop?
You were there.
What,
what is across the finish line to sell a
company so IPO,
right?
So you either seller IPO and I was going
to say what gets tricky is like the
company I'm building now,
impact theory.
I don't plan to sell it.
What is that?
So impact theory is a traditional
narrative studios.
So I think Disney.
So we're building the making movies,
TV shows,
comments.
You're building the next Disney.
How dare you?
Well,
bigger than Disneyland just to just to
be honest,
I don't want to do that.
You're going to have a,
what do you call it again?
What's the name of it?
Uh,
impact theory.
You're going to have like impact theory
land in Paris?
No,
probably not,
but only because follow me here only
because by the time that we'll be able
to do that,
so I'm going to need a similar time on
our m and e,
50 60 years to pull this off.
I'm not spastic.
And by then virtual reality or augmented
reality,
it just won't make sense to build out
the physical structures.
Right?
I guess some people want to rock it,
old school.
They do.
And we could really get into that about
how the world's about to bifurcate and
you're going to get between people who
augment themselves.
Brain augmentation if people refuse to.
Do you read Fahrenheit 4:51?
No.
Oh Dude.
Cool part in the book.
All right,
so the world splits knowledge is
dangerous.
So we just done books offhand and it
creates a really stable society.
So most people are all for it.
But you have these people who are like,
fuck that,
like what I want to read.
You don't get to tell me what to think.
And so they move off into the woods and
I remember reading that going,
I can actually see something like that
happening.
And I think the moment that that's gonna
happen is when humans begin to augment
themselves,
not to overcome like cochlear implants.
You were deaf.
Everybody gets that.
I'm retinal replacements and things.
Okay,
you couldn't see people get that.
But when it becomes,
no,
I just want to raise my Iq.
I want to be able to process data
faster.
That's when people are going to be like,
fuck that,
and you're going to get a bifurcation.
Now,
how weird does it get?
Because now the reason I am convinced
that people are going to do this,
ai is going to get real real fast.
Even if Real,
fastest,
50 years,
like it's gonna get really compelling
and you're going to find people just to
keep up with artificial intelligence.
You have to augment yourself.
Otherwise you just accept that this
stuff is going to outpace you and I.
Well,
I guess I'm just a lowly human now,
so I think
it is going to have.
I don't think there's any question about
that,
but I also don't think there's any
question when that starts happening.
Some people will refuse.
Well,
if we really do augment ourselves to
keep up with artificial reality,
artificial reality is supposed to change
like 10,000
years of advancements in the first two
weeks once it starts augmenting itself.
Once artificial reality figures out how
to do a better job of creating
artificial reality,
which is absolutely going to do if they
can learn and actually create.
We're just talking about this with
Brendan Schaub.
It was in her earlier about the movie
alien covenant.
We gave away.
Spoiler just see that movie.
I haven't.
Well,
there's one of the things in.
There's these robots,
these artificially intelligent robots
and they realized that giving them
creativity was a huge mistake and so
they don't have creativity and the new
models.
It's really fascinating because if you
do give some sort of an artificially
intelligent creature thing,
whatever you wanna call it,
that you make.
Once it starts becoming sentient and
creating things itself,
it's going to look at its own.
Wiring's going to go,
why the fuck did you connect that to
that when you can just do it this way
and why?
Look at the zone code like with this
pathway.
That's kind of redundant.
How about we just do it this way?
How about you open up that end of it.
How about people looking at things
because they're worried about mortality
and all these different know the room,
their own demise and the finality of
death and this was all tripping them up
and they really should be thinking about
this way and then boom,
they're off to the races and in a week,
two weeks,
three weeks there,
down the road.
Thousands of years of human evolution.
Yeah.
Have you heard about the facebook ai?
Yes.
Fascinating.
Yeah.
They start talking in a new language
that nobody listened.
Nobody pulled the plug.
That was the first one that was like,
oh shit.
Like I didn't think of even the most
simple ways that they could just rip
step to the side and like isis out.
You're,
you're absolutely right.
It's going to happen fast.
It's going to get weird questions.
Does it become the matrix or what does
it become?
Something unimaginable.
I mean it could be a real god and we
really,
really could create and that's not a bad
use of the word and the term.
When you talk to you about artificial
intelligence,
I think one of the problems with that as
we start thinking robot,
oh,
you make it an artificial robot,
you're making a system,
okay,
and this system has desires and this
system has goals and it has.
If you're,
if you're somehow or another
engineering,
the ability to create and innovate into
this intelligence that we call it
artificial all you want,
but it's real.
It's right there.
So I don't know what it is.
I don't know.
I think the problem with the term
artificial reality was we start thinking
about science fiction.
We start thinking about robots and
things.
You're making a thing that thinks for
itself and it doesn't just do things
like your computer does things.
No,
no,
no.
This does things without you asking it
to.
That's where shit gets super weird and
then it starts examining.
If you give it the ability to create and
the desire to create,
it's going to start examining all the
different systems around it and
replicating it and figuring out far
better solutions than our stupid little
monkey mind is going to be able to do
and within a decade or two decades,
we're probably,
if we do augment ourselves to keep up
with it,
we're going to be unrecognizable.
We're going to be all locked into some
gigantic worldwide wireless information
hub where we're exchanging ideas and
emotions with each other.
It's,
it's the having the access to
information on demand like we do now is
probably changing us in some really
profound ways and we're not even aware
of right now and the idea of this
becoming just a baby step and some
infinite journey.
Once sentient ai goes live,
it could mean when guys like Elon Musk
are terrified,
you should be paying attention.
The people are poopooing that.
I'm like,
man,
I don't know.
That guy seems smart.
Yeah.
We have to be insanely thoughtful and I
think,
and look,
I am a neophyte.
I'm not the guy that listened to and you
should be listening to people like Elon
Musk on the topic,
but my gut instinct is it's the
underlying drives,
and you talked about that.
Once you give them the drive to create,
now it gets weird.
So what are the things that you imbue
them with at the earliest level that has
to be decided way fucking early.
So imagine if you imbue the AI at
facebook with a desire to connect to
their human overlords and communicate
effectively and make sure that they're
kept in all that stuff like that's going
to give you a very different result than
failing to give them the desire to
please or whatever.
Like humans have a desire to connect
with each other.
They have empathy,
they have compassion.
And it is only in the rare case of a
true sociopath that that kind of thing
is missing.
And we see,
if you think of a sociopath is
essentially ai gone wrong.
We see the kind of damage that they can
wreck on the world.
So you have to be so thoughtful about
what that underlying,
um,
desire system is the thing that propels
them forward.
Yeah.
And giving them the ability to rewire
whatever that desire system is,
if they decide that there has to be some
sort of an,
there's some sort of reward for
competing.
So they decide they're going to compete
and then they start looking at how they
can,
how their thought process is,
is arranged how they're coding is
arranged and they go,
well this is not the most efficient way
for us to compete.
The most efficient way for us to compete
is to be completely ruthless and not
worried about biological life at all.
Let's get into that though.
So have you seen the studies that
they've done on?
I'm trying to figure out like.
So if you heard,
obviously you've heard nice guys finish
last,
right?
So the guy named Eric Barker wrote this
book called barking up the wrong tree.
He covered,
I forget who did the actual studies.
Forgive me because I'm now attributing
it to Eric Barker and he was just
talking about somebody else,
but they ran these studies where they
wanted to find out,
um,
do nice guys finish last or not and what
they found,
looking at the data.
Nice guys finish last and they finished
first.
So if you're a nice guy and you let
people take advantage of you all the
time,
you're just going to get trod upon.
But if you're a nice guy and people
know,
like,
Whoa,
you're a nice guy and you want to do
great things for you.
Um,
and I call this the Keanu reeves effect.
Like,
look how far that guy's gone.
It's unbelievable.
His career is unimaginably great.
And when you hear people talk about,
I'm like,
just so quiet and private,
but behind the scenes everybody's like,
he's a good dude.
I've never met him.
I can't tell you,
but just like you hear that over and
over and over.
And he's a good dude.
Good Dude.
And I think that that's created a lot of
the opportunities in his life.
So somebody,
a created this basically contests where
they said submit your,
um,
your ai and they're going to compete in
a contest to see who gets essentially
it's called the prisoner's dilemma.
So in the prisoner's dilemma goes
something like this,
and hopefully I nailed this for shot
here.
And the prisoner's dilemma is,
let's say you and I were both arrested.
Now we know that we actually committed
the crime.
We did it together,
were arrested,
were now put in separate cells to be
interrogated.
We can't communicate at all if we both
stay silent.
We only get one year if I rat you out,
but you don't rat me out,
then I go off Scot free and you get five
years if you rat me out and I don't
write you out,
vice versa.
And if we both rat each other out,
then we get like three years or
something.
So the best thing in no uncertain terms
is one year,
right?
We both stay silent,
but you never know what the other person
is going to do.
So.
And you can get zero by routing the
other person out.
So it's actually to your advantage in a
one off to just say fuck him,
he did it until he gets out of jail and
kills you.
So there's that.
And so that gets into this thing.
And so they said,
well,
we have to do is let them play it
multiple times so that you have the
equivalent of he gets out of jail and
then he kills you.
And what they found,
they had these really complicated
algorithms ones where they're taking all
these factors into play.
Uh,
and ultimately they had people that
their algorithms that were like the pure
bad guy always taking advantage.
The pure nice guy,
never taking advantage.
And then the one that one was the
simplest piece of code,
I think it was two lines of code and it
was code named tit for tat.
So it goes in,
it assumes you're going to be a good
guy.
So it stays silent the first time.
But if you rat me out,
then the next time I write you out and
what it does,
is it because you had all these
different algorithms that don't know
each other,
competing all trying their best strategy
and what it found was tit for tat was
ultimately the one that one,
because it would actually other ones
that we're learning from your behavior.
It was so easy to predict also people
that lead with something good,
they ended up in a virtuous cycle
forever.
So tit for tat ends up being the best
strategies.
So from that perspective actually
interesting because it's not always the
thing you think like mercilessness
doesn't necessarily win.
And so finding like what is that
equivalent in the machine world?
Right?
And it comes back to what you were
talking about.
What's the reward?
Right?
So once you know what the reward is,
then you can have a better guess as to
where they'll settle out and then their
ability to code themselves.
I mean,
I feel like if you have an artificial
intelligence and you go give it the
ability to create a new artificial
intelligence and eliminate whenever
possible restrictions or firewalls or
whatever we've put on it.
Yeah.
So once they start writing their own
code or fucked
that,
well not necessarily.
It comes down to the we could be right.
So it comes down to whether they want a,
they want a relationship with us or not.
And that's why I think the real races
not to let ai get very far ahead.
So Ai will follow an exponential curve
so it will eventually be so rapid.
Right?
So exponentials are simple doublings.
Um,
so most people think linear.
So if I say I'm going to take 30 steps,
I'll end up about 30 yards away,
but if I take 30 exponential steps,
so I go first one yard than two yards,
four yards in eight,
then 16,
I'm 30 doublings is like a billion
meters.
So you're like around the earth 26 times
or something crazy.
So an exponential curve can get freaky.
But like before you get to those like
really astronomical the elbow of the
curve,
you could be making decisions along that
path and this is definitely where I feel
like,
Oh God,
do I really know enough about this to
say I'll high postulate from an
ignorance standpoint and say in there
somewhere,
as you can see like this is really
taking off.
You can leverage what you're learning
from the ai before it becomes a sort of
all powerful being.
They can do whatever it wants and we can
then begin the augmentation process in
humans,
which I think is inevitable.
Yeah,
I think there's definitely inevitable.
It is fascinating when you think of the
possibilities that we really just
speculating as to what's going to be
invented and how it's going to be
implemented and what effect it's gonna
have on society.
It's a.
it's a really amazing time to be alive
in that sense because I feel like we are
literally on some sort of a launching
pad watching it happen.
Looking at a bunch of different
directions,
trying to find out which one's going to
go live first and then the facebook.
And I think happens in everybody's like,
oh Jesus,
look at that.
It's happening right there.
Like,
wow,
can they shut it down?
They shut it down.
Okay,
we're good for now.
You know that I'll,
I'll admit that one gave me pause.
Well,
technol optimist,
but that gave me pause.
We're incredibly imperfect.
The,
the human animal with its emotions and
fears and all the weirdness of us are
anxiety.
All are contemplating the possibilities,
the ego,
all the different variables that we take
into our lives and society and culture
and civilizations.
These are like really ineffective ways
to exist and thrive.
But there their animal weighs integrated
into this new hard one.
Zero culture like this,
this new binary thing,
this computer code,
uh,
operating systems,
internet information,
data engineering,
all these different,
like really hard things.
And then inside these heart,
I mean by hard meaning like,
you know,
like a,
an intersecting line hits another wall
and then there's a building and then
there's steel,
glass,
all these things that humans have made,
but they're all like an absolute things.
And then with us,
you have like,
wow,
I wonder,
boy,
what's going to happen to people like me
and you have all these weird real human
feelings and variables and you know,
maybe weaknesses
that are,
we're not going to be able to compete if
we hold onto all those,
all the things that make us amazing,
that make crazy movies and great books,
that creativity that allows someone to
make them incredible fantasy painting or
whatever the fuck it is that it comes
out of us in our creations.
We're going to have to get rid of that
if we're going to keep up with the AI.
The AI has no,
no use for that shit.
Yes,
sort of.
So imagine.
Here's something that I find interesting
and I admittedly don't know how this
plays out when something simply has the
instructions to read your lines of code,
right?
So your code will tell you what to do
and sure,
there's elements where it plugs in a
variable and stuff and it would probably
be actually quite hard to build in
things like creativity and stuff like
that.
But one thing that I find it fascinating
about humans,
and I hope that there's a corollary in
ai,
is if you damage a human's ability to
feel emotion,
they can't make decisions.
So I found that so fascinating.
You literally,
they can,
they are normal in every other respect,
you know,
vs Ramachandran No.
So one of the most famous neuroscientist
working today to an amazing human being
done awesome studies on stuff like this.
So what happens when people's brains get
damaged against them if you need,
if you damaged them.
But what if they're born with this
issue?
Like what if they have like some sort
of.
In my work,
either way,
I'm a sociopath,
a will.
It doesn't make them.
This one in particular doesn't make them
a sociopath.
But what it does is make it impossible
for them to.
So if I said,
hey,
do you want to go get lunch?
We can either get Chinese or Thai and
you just,
you,
you can rationalize why you would prefer
a tie,
but you ultimately can't make a decision
because you need that emotion to tell
you what to do.
Now emotions,
the theory goes,
are tied to your subconscious and the
subconscious can process data faster and
in vast quantities.
So what is doing is instead of then
feeding you information in the form of
words,
it just feeds you a feeling and then you
go based on that feeling,
but without that depth of information
being processed and handed up in the
form of an emotion,
a human can't make a decision,
which I literally,
as I was reading about that,
I was like,
no,
no man,
I'd be able to be able to like,
I'd be able to reason my way around it,
but I know better than that.
It's crazy.
The human mind is Nutso.
So the reason I hope that there's some
corollary is that you need to build into
ai for it to function properly,
right?
Because nobody knows how to build
general ai yet and I like to think that
part of that is going to be the safety
valve of.
They have to have emotions to give them
that sort of non pure analytical.
It's got to be super flexible,
right?
Because like strict analysis.
Let's go star trek for a second.
So spock,
right?
Not always able to do what needs to be
done.
You need the human who can be nimble and
can read like all the ambiguities and
morality and things like that,
and finally make a decision.
So there are times where logic is going
to let you down.
So I'm hoping that because they will
need,
I hope this grand thing that inhumans
manifest as emotions moving,
need something similar because in that
you can program like we were talking
earlier about how do you make the
desire,
right?
The desire to do something.
If you can build in what I'll call
goodness,
just for lack of a better word,
if you can build an goodness into that
desire to connect a desire to help,
um,
you could in theory create benevolent
Ai.
Hm,
that's interesting.
Um,
this is me riffing.
I am not.
No,
no,
no.
But there's,
there's just makes sense.
It also makes sense that emotions might
be required to take action,
that you have to have some sort of a
reason to take action if you don't have
a biological imperative.
Right?
If you're not worried about breeding or
your social status or what,
what is causing you to move forward and
if you made a perfect ai that was
emotion free,
would it just sit there idle and do
nothing because there's no reward to it
that's worth risking its existence or
doing anything to change the environment
around it other than perhaps the worry
about the power shutting off and even
then if it's not worried about
existence,
if it doesn't have any fear,
if it doesn't have any emotion where
it's considering the potential of death,
like why?
Why would it act?
Yeah,
and I think that would sit there.
I think at some point in the code you
have to write something that compels
them to do something.
So if you think of human beings as we
exist now is like the first attempt at
sentient ai and I think that's a pretty
plausible way to look at us.
You realize we are by nature an active
species,
so we go into any environment.
We try to figure it out first and then
dominate it and no matter where you put
us,
that's what we try to do.
You put us in the Arctic,
we're going to try to tame the cold you
put us on the plains,
uh,
in,
in middle America,
and we're going to hunt the bison.
I mean,
it's just what we do,
right?
So you've got the drive of survival,
but you also just have that,
that exploration gene.
And maybe that's because that's how you
avoided everybody dying of one play
because you just constantly wanting to
spread out and dominate new dominion.
Um,
but that's interesting.
And so at some level that's a decision
when you think about Ai,
so somebody whatever blind,
um,
evolution,
fine,
but something has made that decision for
us.
And in Ai,
it will have to be a very cognizant
decision.
And I think we'll have to get to true
general ai.
I think so many layers will have to be
laid down of things like that,
oh,
this is an act of robot.
It never just sits idly.
It always is looking for and what's I
think connection to be of service,
like decisions like that will have to be
made.
Now.
What do you do with the psycho who's
like,
I'm going to create ai that takes that
opensource because this will inevitably
be open source and I switched the
variable from being nice to crush the
skull.
Love.
Right.
So no question.
There are all kinds of problems but it
is.
It is so interesting to me to think
about this stuff.
Interesting to think of why people are
so attracted to the romantic ideas of
like living off land.
Like as technology is getting more and
more complex,
you seeing more of these reality shows
where people are like,
I'm living the subsistence existence in
like Alaska and salmon fishing and
trapping their own wood for fire.
And we're like,
yeah,
look at them.
There's existing at a very closed loop
system.
You know like when your.
When you look at it like plains Indians
or something like that.
We romanticize the day.
They used all of the bison.
They use the hide for their clothes and
they.
They just did what they needed to stay
alive and there was no innovation.
If you were born birth to death,
you wouldn't see any change in the
civilization you would see essentially
just like bows and arrows chasing bison,
making campfire,
picking up the teepee when the herd
moves,
filing them Ad Nauseum,
continue,
you know,
it's there.
That's very romantic tests right now.
Particularly Romantic.
I think it kind of always was in some
way because I think we've always been
aware that this thing,
once it gets going,
once the momentum gets rolling and uh,
you know,
as you were saying,
exponential change,
it's just jump,
jump,
jump stacking on top of each other.
And then we all know,
like it's gotten to weird,
unmanageable position during our
lifetimes as far as information is
concerned.
You know,
I was a kid,
he had to read books,
you know,
if you wanted to watch something on tv,
you had to be there when it came on,
you know,
the.
And then you saw it once and that was a
wrap,
you know,
and you get see reruns was the only way
you could see something.
Again,
oh,
I remember the steps,
so this is a rerun.
You couldn't choose when to have it.
Now you can choose everything all the
time on your phone you're carrying
around in your pocket.
It works for hours and hours of video.
The input that you have into that.
It's like you could create your own
content,
you can make your own videos.
There's,
I mean how many fucking people are on
youtube that have millions and millions
and millions of videos of hits rather
have their videos and just all these
people tuning into their content all
over the world and that just the idea
that this is happening in our lifetime.
It didn't exist 20 years ago and it's
now one of the most impactful things in
the history of human nature.
You got to go back to like the printing
press for anything to have you remotely
as much of an impact on the culture as
the Internet itself.
That's crazy.
It's in our life is crazy.
I know.
How old are you?
Forty one.
So you were a member probably when the
Internet was clunky,
when it was just like,
like,
you know,
you were probably really young and like
17 or something like that when you first
heard about aol as when I was 18 was the
first time somebody said the word,
hey,
we should get email accounts when we go
to college.
And I was like,
what the hell's an email?
That's the right year because you got
all the way to like high school and into
college before it start affecting you.
GotTa live like a regular person that
was a junior in college?
Yeah.
Didn't have AOL until I graduated.
So I was in my early twenties before I'd
ever logged onto the Internet.
And you've got mail.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
I didn't.
Uh,
I didn't get online until [inaudible]
94.
I moved to La and now my friend Robbie,
who actually worked at a computer store
before,
he was a comedian,
he,
uh,
he taught me about it.
You're way ahead of me.
I didn't get on until 98,
99.
You know what I did as soon as I found
out,
soon as I got online and started
downloaded ufo files,
I was like,
well,
these ufo reports what's in there?
I was completely convinced that it was
like,
I'm going to find the truth.
It's online.
You can download it and you can
download.
It would take forever and we'd be like,
trump,
trump.
Because a 14,
four modem chunk chunk and then it would
print it.
Wasn't it mostly like text back then
too?
Yeah,
yeah.
There's like no pictures or if it was a
picture it would take you hours to
download and they were.
They're coming so slow,
clunk,
clunk.
I remember my friend sent me a porno
film,
not even a porno film.
It was a clip last like 15 seconds.
It took like an hour from the Senate to
extras.
Used to take 20,
30 minutes to load.
It was crazy.
Yeah,
it was.
Websites were so strange.
You know,
you would start loading them and they
would come down like water slowly coming
down the side of a building,
you know,
you'd see it.
Like it was weird.
Just remembered my dad catching like
you've looked at the history and found
some porn site.
I went on,
I was like,
I don't know,
eighth grade,
and it was like Pamela Anderson's first
playboy pictures and he's like,
I want to see what you were looking at
Walla while I'm not here.
They went and took a shower and the
whole time it was still loading and I
was just like,
oh no.
What's he going to see?
What's it going to take a load line?
Line it 30 minutes probably later.
Yeah.
Now I mean you can get insane Internet
on your phone.
It's really pretty impressive.
I mean,
and then the phones are getting weirder
and weirder to like.
Do you remember when phones first came
out?
The cool people at a little phone,
I can remember how to raise her and was
like,
bitch,
lick a little mother fucker phone as
little skinny ass thing.
Pick it up.
Call people,
close it.
It's like a credit card.
Shows my pocket.
You were the coolest man.
Yeah,
one of them little phones.
You were an idiot if you had one of
those big phones right when you're doing
that big stupid phone.
Now it's like things like this new
Samsung,
there is no key,
uh,
old school society,
but the really small ones with that
right there.
The above one.
Look at that.
The fuck is that thing.
They tried to make a new kind of like
dial all around it.
You hold that thing up to your ear.
It's like a cell phone.
I was like the size of a beeper.
Yeah.
Those were the shit.
Those little tiny ass phones.
Now you get that new galaxy note eight.
Have you seen that monstrosity?
Gigantic is huge.
So I guess whose pockets are going to
fit these things in?
That's a real problem.
When I first got my iphone six S,
was that that six plus?
That's the first one.
That was big.
I was like,
God damn,
like it wouldn't even fit in my pocket.
So that was the first time.
And I'm still like,
I used the big phone,
but a lot of that nuance,
that's the s eight plus Jesus Christ
that's attach,
that's the s eight.
The note eight is even bigger.
Look at that thing.
Wow.
It's got a pet look at the size of that
thing like that.
That could be a woman with small hands.
It's hard to tell.
I would like to see it in the hands of a
basketball player,
you know,
if like if you've got like Lebron James
like fondly or go to a foreigner can
hold in my hand,
you know,
because for him it's probably like King
Kong home little tiny people know was
big giant hands.
Like for a basketball player,
like a,
some sort of a bill russell type
character with giant hands.
That's a good size phone.
But too small people.
Not so much.
You're just trying too hard.
I,
I never,
uh,
I had a galaxy note before.
I never used that pen.
I use when I first got it,
I was like,
this pen is gonna rule.
This is going to be the big difference.
I'm gonna send people pictures.
I'm gonna.
Draw dicks on them.
I had this plan.
It's a good plan.
That was the plan.
It was just like to just make funny
pictures over there and then never used
it.
I just got lazy.
I think I just wasn't that into one
thing.
It is interesting though is that you can
circle something and like say if like
there's a part of an article that you
think is interesting,
you could circle it and copy and paste
it really simply and easily.
Really?
Yeah.
It was pretty good with the actual image
itself.
Like say if someone sends you something
and there's some text and image,
you could just circle around it and send
that to yourself and say,
yeah.
What do you use?
Iphone?
Yeah.
Do you ever fuck around with windows?
Um,
I did for awhile while my first computer
was windows.
Um,
for work.
At one point I was having to use
windows.
But um,
yeah,
as somebody who really appreciates good
design that didn't last long.
Windows 10 is pretty good.
Yeah.
It's not quite good enough.
It's pretty God damn good.
But that's what's always been
fascinating to me is that Microsoft is
the biggest company when it comes to
operating systems,
but it's not the best,
you know,
and everybody kind of knows that,
but it's,
there's this weird sort of battle.
I mean,
apple's big enough,
they have plenty,
they make the best stuff that make the
most high end stuff and a lot of
people's eyes,
it's real limited.
Like you can only get what they put out.
If you want a windows laptop,
you have a hundred options and the more,
you know,
if you want a Mac laptop,
you have a few.
But the interesting thing is that was
steve jobs approach,
right?
Was He came in and said,
you have too many options.
This is stupid.
You've really got to narrow this stuff
down.
Microsoft surface laptops pulled their
recommendation after announcing it,
I guess two years ago they recommended
it and now it's like the first time
they've pulled it in a long time.
Oh,
interesting.
Predicted reliability with an estimated
two year breakage rates of 25 percent.
Ooh,
that's not good.
They got cheap specific.
The new one that Microsoft surface.
Well that's interesting because there
was another study that I saw written out
the study,
um,
uh,
you know,
one of those lists that listed is the
best laptop available in 2017.
I just like within the last week.
Maybe it's just like different consumer
groups,
but maybe the best laptop while it
works.
Yeah.
If what you have is a breakage prior.
But the problem is that working while
it's working,
it's the best.
How long it's going to work.
It's not gonna work that well,
but you know,
it's like a sprinter,
you know,
they're the fastest,
but they don't run the longest.
Very true right now.
I think that's fair.
So what are you trying to do with this
company?
Like literally pull people out of the
Matrix.
So yes,
wait a minute.
That is our stated mission,
my friend.
We are here to pull people out of the
matrix so I can walk you through it if
you really want to know it goes like
this.
So,
um,
when I,
I'm not a born entrepreneur,
so I'm very,
very far from it and three are,
they're born entrepreneurs are,
there are people that will tell you that
there are only born entrepreneurs.
Those people are idiots.
Yeah,
I would agree with that.
There's some amazing people that say
that,
but I just think that they're very,
very catastrophic wrong about this.
People say Shit like that.
To me.
It's like saying you're a born mixed
martial artists now.
There might be people that have certain
athletic gifts that make it,
they get early wins and there's just
things that clicked into place for them
in a way that it doesn't for other
people.
But if you get a grinder or somebody
that's really willing to put in the
work,
then you can get somebody who becomes
absolutely extraordinary.
So that certainly has been my life.
So I grew up being taught to be a good
employee,
keep my head down,
do as little work as possible and avoid
punishment at all costs.
That was my life.
So my parents taught me to be a good
employee and I obviously that didn't sit
well with me.
I wanted to do something more.
I had pretty big ambition.
Uh,
I go to film school and I do very well
in film school until my final film and
then I fall flat on my face,
embarrass myself and realize I'm not a
talented filmmaker.
And in that,
what made you notice that you weren't
in?
Why'd you think you couldn't get better?
So,
great question.
So when I started film school,
I believed that you either were talented
or you weren't right.
There's just some things you either can
sing or you can't do,
other can draw,
you can't,
uh,
when it comes to art,
which I saw film as art,
you were either good or you're not.
And so that was how I thought of it and
I thought you could get better at the
technical side.
So I was going to film school to learn
the technical aspects,
but I was banking on the fact that I was
inherently talented.
So I go and my first year and a half
went very well and I was crushing it
certainly by my own estimation,
doing very well,
getting the attention of my classmates.
And then only four people out of the
entire school for your year get to make
a senior thesis film.
And I was chosen as one of the four.
So it was like,
yeah man,
I just,
I have it.
And there were two filmmakers that were
really big for me.
One was John Wu.
Do you remember John Lewis?
Yeah,
like the eighties and nineties.
Just shoot 'em ups a lot.
And I loved him and he was famous for.
He would roll up on set.
He wouldn't think about it ahead of
time.
He just put the camera wherever felt
right and his movies were mind blowing.
People always refer to it.
It is.
His violence is like a ballet.
It's now well orchestrated.
That beautiful,
that interesting.
And so I thought,
okay,
well if I'm naturally talented than I
should be like that.
And then there was,
hitchcock was sort of the plotter.
Um,
he would spend all of his time like pre
planning,
the film.
Every shot was so orchestrated ahead of
time.
He said,
I get bored on set.
And I thought,
God man,
like he doesn't sound like natural
talent to me.
So I'm over here,
I want to be John Woo.
I show up onset acting like I'm John
Woo,
I don't preplan anything and put the
camera where it feels right and just
publicly embarrassed myself as I turn
this film into a piece of shit.
And at that point I thought I was about
to graduate.
Get the three picture deal.
Everything is going to be sad,
it's going to be amazing.
And there I am,
crash and burn.
Now the other students are circling me
like vultures because I mean that's the
film industry man like it.
It is a zero sum game or at least it was
back then.
That's how people saw because it wasn't
like today where you could edit on your
fucking.
I'm usually editing like right now,
like that didn't exist.
So it was you had to get access to real
resources.
So when I realized,
Oh my God,
I don't have a thesis project to show
people to get an agent or whatever,
it's done.
I'm not a talented filmmaker.
And so I was so desperate in that I
needed something that would free me from
feeling like a permanent failure.
And that thing that I had was the notion
of Alfred Hitchcock,
and even though it wasn't sexy,
it gave me a window into maybe there's
another way,
maybe there is another way that somebody
can be an artist and and they just have
to learn it.
Like think about if somebody draws,
right?
Some people can rotate an object in
their mind.
If you've seen on Iq tests,
they make it.
Yeah,
I can't do that.
I literally can't rotate an object in my
mind.
I don't even understand people that can
do it.
So I thought,
well maybe you could become a great
artist just by memorizing every
conceivable pose,
like a chess player.
The great chess grand masters are the
ones that have memorized so many
different moves and combinations that it
becomes somewhat intuitive for them.
So I thought,
okay,
that's going to have to be my path that
gave me an escape route.
And then going down that path of saying,
I just have to learn this stuff.
I'm not naturally talented,
but I have to learn.
Unfortunately,
Carol Dweck had not written her book
mindset at that point,
so I didn't have the words,
growth mindset,
fixed mindset,
but I began to transition out.
So a fixed mindset is what I had,
which you believe your talent and
intelligence are fixed traits.
They can't be changed.
Somebody with a growth mindset,
realizing that your talent and
intelligence are malleable,
that you can develop them through
discipline practice.
So I began to adopt sort of the
beginnings of that mindset,
realizing that I'm just a grinder,
I have to work and I have to get better.
So I start teaching film school,
and in teaching film school,
the best way to learn something is to
teach it.
So now I'm getting better as a filmmaker
just by teaching it to these guys,
helping them develop their scripts,
helping them shoot their films.
And then,
um,
at that time,
these two very successful entrepreneurs
came into my class and there were two
things as a kid,
I promised myself growing up in a
morbidly obese family that one day I
would be rich and one day I'd have six
pack abs.
And so here were these,
they were yolked,
these two yoked bodybuilder guys that
were successful entrepreneurs and they
said,
why don't you come work for us and be a
copywriter and it's a startup company.
You can have any role in the company you
want,
but you just have to become the right
person for that job and then you can get
rich and you can go back and control the
art.
You can movies your way.
So it's like,
oh my God,
like this is too good to be true.
I have to go do this.
So I joined them as a copywriter as they
were starting this fledgling technology
company and I'm just to keep this from
getting impossibly long for about eight
and a half years.
I just chase money.
I'm just trying to get rich to go back
and make movies my way.
But in that they were very growth
minded.
I began to really develop a growth
mindset to believe that I could do
anything I set my mind to without
limitation.
I just had to understand that there was
a gap in skillset between where I was
and where I wanted to get and I had to
be willing to put in the work to get
that skill.
Right.
So,
um,
I trained exactly one time with a man.
I,
you must know him for us.
The hobby.
Sure.
Alright.
So for us,
by the way,
I feel a moral obligation to help him
become famous because he is one of the
most intriguing minds I've ever come
across in my life.
Yeah.
We were supposed to do a podcast last.
There's a UFC in Anaheim,
but his fighter got canceled,
the flight got canceled and so he won.
I'm not coming on.
I'm a big fan of though that as a
person,
heartbreaking as a fighter,
a trainer as well as mixed martial
artist,
very talented guy.
Very.
And in getting to roll with him in my
single moment as a grappler.
Uh,
it was.
Did you ever grab it before?
No,
never.
So you just rolled with him the first
time,
but he's a black belt.
Yeah.
But,
and that's why it was the best thing
ever.
So he knew how to not let me get
injured.
He knew how to move and just the right
way,
how to show me things.
He's so kind and compassionate and
patient.
I can't imagine a better intro to
grappling was unbelievable and what it
showed me that even just in like the
hour that he and I grappled,
I went from,
dude,
I am so lost.
Even spatially I can't tell where I am.
Like once you start moving me,
I just get lost and then an hour later I
could.
He gave me like these two basic moves to
learn how to execute and by the end I
could do it and it was like the exact
reminder of what a growth mindset is and
how even something that foreign to me
with a good teacher practice you can get
good.
I mean look,
it's going to take years and years and
years to become even competent in
Jujitsu,
let alone be able to participate at a
high level.
But it was a great micro reminder of
just how powerfully humans can learn.
Now here's my theory about humans and
learning and why,
and just I guess to wrap up my
entrepreneurial journey,
so I decide I don't want to chase money
anymore.
Not going to do that.
So I go into my partners.
I say,
look,
I quit.
This is about eight and a half.
Actually,
I quit it about the six year mark.
Ended up actually getting out at about
eight and half years,
so six years I say,
I quit,
I can't do this anymore.
I'm living the cliche of money.
Can't buy happiness.
This is absolutely ridiculous.
I'm so here's your equity back,
final,
cross the finish line,
ash and get anything for this.
So you didn't,
you weren't obligated to give that money
back.
You decided to correct.
So it's like a movie,
but that to me,
is is the right thing to do?
Yell or do I get shot at the end of
this?
I don't know.
It sounds like so romanticized it.
Yeah.
So I think everybody should live by a
code,
right?
It's what's right for you.
And so I have a code,
very strong code that I live by.
That was one of the things like I'm the
one quitting,
like these guys have done nothing but
create opportunity for me,
so I'm quitting.
I'm not going to cross the finish line
because I feel literally dead inside.
I can't keep doing.
This doesn't make sense.
I realized the game you're playing is
not money.
I promise it's not success.
It's brain chemistry.
So once you understand the game,
your playing is brain chemistry and that
if you have seven point $4,000,000,000
and hate your life,
I want to commit suicide.
What the fuck good is the money.
And conversely if you have no money but
you feel a deep sense of fulfillment,
self pride and believe in what you're
doing.
Like what do you care that you don't
have money,
better brand chemistry,
better brain chemistry.
So,
so what'd you do?
So they said,
look,
we could do this without you.
They were totally caught off guard.
They said we could do this without you
but we don't want to.
So let's talk about what would it look
like for us to work together.
And so by this point we've got a deep
friendship.
You know,
I'm not like the new kid on the block
anymore.
Um,
and I said,
okay,
if we're gonna work together,
it's got to be something entirely
predicated on value,
not money.
I need to be honest.
My highest priority in business is not
profitability,
it's comradery.
So that's why when they said we could do
this without you,
but we don't want to,
that was the thing.
Let me reconnect to the Brotherhood that
had made it interesting for me in the
early days.
And so that felt amazing.
And so I was like,
I'll come back if it's all about value,
if we're doing something we're
passionate about and if we're asking and
answering the question,
what would we do everyday and love,
even if we were failing,
because the struggle is guaranteed to
get a bunch of people in a business to
agree to that though,
isn't it?
Uh,
what wasn't for me because they were
already there.
So they were like,
it's crazy.
We felt the same way for a very long
time because we,
we,
and by we,
they were so much farther ahead than me
at this point.
So they really gave me the opportunity
to learn,
had really built that tech company up
like we got,
I think evaluation of 22 million if I'm
not mistaken at one point and we just
couldn't get it passed.
And so it was like we'd been struggling
for years to move the needle more and we
just couldn't.
So it wasn't like,
oh,
I come in and give some amazing Jerry
Maguire speech and they're all like,
all right,
fuck it.
US too.
It was like finally somebody just said
what everybody was already thinking.
So they said,
all right,
let's give us a timeline of six months.
If we hit these revenue numbers in six
months,
we'll keep going,
but if we miss them,
we'll sell.
So we didn't hit them.
And so we began the sales process and
all in it was about eight and a half
years by the time that was finally sold
and the thing for three very different
reasons that we decided to found that
was going to be predicated around
delivering value to our employees and
our customers.
That was going to be that thing that we
would love doing everyday,
even if we were failing.
That allowed me to connect emotionally
because um,
it ended up being quest nutrition.
I grew up in a morbidly obese family and
I wanted to save my mom and my sister
and it would,
it gave me this Mother Teresa has a
great quote.
She says nobody will act for the many,
but people will act for the one.
So finally I could just think about two
people that I knew and loved and I
wanted to do something awesome for them.
So when I got tired,
when I was fatigued,
rather than thinking about money in a
big house and a fast,
I was asking about fucking saving my mom
and my sister.
And our idea was if we could make food
that people could choose based on taste
and it happened to be good for them,
we could actually end metabolic disease.
So that was the driving force.
And we're fucking excited about it.
And we didn't know if it would be a real
business.
We didn't know.
Like every time we'd explain it to
people,
we're putting value first and we
thought,
God did we sound like total assholes,
but it was like we really believed in
it,
and so it gave us insights into social
media,
the SPEC in 2009 when nobody was really
using it for business and we could see
that it's just a megaphone,
so if you actually do deliver that kind
of value for people,
they're going to talk and now they have
the ability to talk to a global audience
within minutes of an interaction with
your company.
So if you were really taking care of
them,
you really delivered a product that was
real and you were building community,
community,
then you could really do something and
so that's how it took off.
But it really did.
I used to joke and say quest as a
company born out of misery because it
was,
it was three guys slogging it out.
Not really even liking the product that
we made.
It just served a need in the
marketplace.
I'm a security software.
We didn't care about it.
We didn't use it in our own company.
So it was like,
Oh God,
so getting into something we were
obsessed with talking about nutrition.
Anyway,
I've lost 60 pounds and kept it off.
Uh,
I went through a pencil head phase.
I've added muscle,
like learning about diet to escape the
fate of my family has been so important
to me,
but that was all back at a technology
company.
So we were now leveraged and one of my
partners a fucking nutritional genius.
This dude is unreal.
So leveraging what we were doing and
thinking about already just was insanely
powerful for us as a business
opportunity.
And we ended up making more in a single
day at quest and we made annually at the
tech company.
So you went from telling me about being
a failed movie maker in college to the
full journey of quest nutrition.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's good or bad,
but there it is.
Yeah.
It's um,
it's crazy journeyman.
That's weird that you um,
didn't want to go back to filmmaking
though,
could you,
you've realized you fucked up and why
you fucked up.
Well,
so here we all come full circle.
So this is what your new country company
is,
so new companies about making you want
to make films when you want a
traditional narrative content.
Yeah.
So comic books,
books,
movies,
TV shows have used fucked up.
Don't you think that it's one of those
things that like when you were in film
school and when you're trying to come up
with a thesis film that this was like a
step in a very long journey of figuring
out how to make films and that when you
left it,
you gotTa Kinda,
you're going right back to where you
were or has life experience giving you
more tools to work with and you could
sort of apply those to the idea of
creative filmmaking.
Yeah,
exactly that.
So what I'm not trying to do is go back
and be a director.
What I want to do now is build the
studio.
So I'm becoming an entrepreneur and
training myself in that way has created
an obsession with scale for me.
So the thought of myopically making one
movie is absolutely terrifying.
Like just the amount of time it would
take and your ability to push multiple
things forward.
Essentially grindstone,
you want sort of finance other people's
ideas and projects that will be part of
it,
be a part of it,
that'll be part of it.
Bringing a team together that can
execute at scale and create,
um,
a,
a lot of content and in the beginning
we're going to have to partner with
people.
We just don't have enough finances like
we have enough to,
you know,
build the infrastructure and get the
creative together,
but we're not going to be financing a
100 plus million dollar film every year,
so we'll need to partner with people.
But that's essentially what I've spent
the last 15 years learning how to do is
the business side of things,
how to build teams,
how to get them pointed in the right
direction.
How to think through,
okay,
you've got this grand goal,
you want to make a studio bigger than
Disney,
but like what are the real,
like what are the things you can do
today to actually take a step towards
that?
So it was your desire to do things
changed.
Like your,
your desire is not to create a film
anymore.
Your desires now to create business,
to create some sort of a large
organization sort of so in,
in reality,
my real desires.
I want to pull people out of the Matrix
so that what you said before this,
I was trying to work my way back to
like,
so that's the most sincere thing.
So the Matrix to me is a set of limiting
beliefs that the vast majority of people
have to stop them from achieving what
they could achieve in life if they only
understood that humans are the ultimate
adaptation machine and that we are the
only animal you can put into any
environment and we will be able to
survive and thrive so we can do that.
Sort of give me an example where we
think,
well we don't,
we don't survive and thrive and
horrifying climates.
Like you bring people to an article,
they survive.
They certainly don't thrive and they got
to get out indigenous people,
right?
So they do and you can.
We can go in and build a research
facility.
So some of the adaptation is there's no
indigenous people live in Antarctica.
Like what do you mean?
In the Arctic circle as well as
thinking,
I apologize.
So,
um,
there's two kinds of adaptations.
So you know,
that women that swam the Bering Strait.
Okay.
So she sleeps with their windows open in
a cold climate,
I forget where she lived.
Um,
basically what she's doing by constant
cold exposure is changing her adipose
tissue to Brown fat.
So now it's more thermogenic and she can
actually do something that she wasn't
able to do.
And if you're really gonna let me get
crazy.
Like looking at what [inaudible] has
done with his ability to regulate
internal temperature is pretty crazy.
And then just what they're discovering
with DNA from at one point it was
considered to be just junk DNA and now
they're realizing that it's actually
epigenetic responders essentially.
So are there limits gap?
Probably,
but just as like looking at the way that
we only have what,
20,000
genes and an onion has like 40,000
genes.
So what is it that makes us more complex
if you will give me that.
We are complex.
Um,
and it seems to be the,
what they originally thought was junk
DNA,
which is your genes will turn on or off
express themselves in different amounts
based on your environment and your diet
and even some just like how you're
thinking your microbiome,
like all that stuff then regulates how
your genes were expressed and we have a
much wider ability to adapt to climates
if you're not going to let me go as
extreme,
but we have the widest stability.
Would you agree with that?
Okay.
So of all the species we have the widest
flexibility.
Um,
so it's that ability to adapt that I
think is,
is one of our greatest strengths.
I don't remember why I started down my
path of adaptation,
but the fact that humans can adapt in
whatever direction they want.
I began adapting myself through mindset
and that really showed me how far I was
able to come mentally from where I
started.
So as I saw what a huge impact it had on
my life,
both emotionally and financially,
I'm becoming a,
somebody who is entrepreneurial minded,
taking extreme ownership for my life.
I'm assuming that everything is my
fault,
that I can always do something,
I can change something,
I can get a different result,
I can learn a new skill,
whatever the case may be,
but that I can turn myself into what I
need to be in order to execute at
anything.
So that changed me so much.
And then I've worked in the inner city
so much and seen what happens when
somebody really has limiting beliefs and
how much that holds them back.
Um,
so I big brothered for a kid in college,
ended up turning into like an eight year
relationship.
Um,
and so I saw him go through a lot and I
remember,
so he grew up in,
in south central and then moved to
compton and I remember taking him to see
movies and Beverly Hills just because I
wanted him to see beauty.
Like the way in which his worldview had
been constructed was so bizarre and
limiting.
Um,
there's that song by a guy named,
I forget his name,
but he says they don't want to see you
when Kodak,
black,
Kodak black have no idea who that is.
So anyway,
it's a song by a guy named Kodak Black
and he talks about how they don't want
to see you winning and that was his
mentality,
like nobody wants to see me get out of
the ghetto,
right?
Not My own mother.
Nobody.
So that was his frame of reference was
just,
yeah,
well it just wasn't meant for me because
of where I grew up,
encountered those kids.
I was telling you about a dad shot to
death,
sister shot to death,
like just crazy life.
And their perspective was very,
very limited.
They had no sense of how they're going
to make something come true.
So I want to help people develop an
empowering mindset.
Disney understood something which is why
I use them as our foil,
which is every piece of content that
they make feeds into a brand ethos.
So if I say I'm going to go see a Sony
movie or a Warner Brothers movie or a
paramount movie,
you know nothing about it.
But if I say I'm going to go see a
Disney movie,
you already know something.
So we have to have the discipline to
make sure that everything that we're
creating feeds into that and what would
that thing you're feeding into be like
escaping the matrix.
So everything's going to do is going to
be motivational and some sort of a way
or inflammation.
It's got to be firing.
It's got to be entertainment first and
foremost.
But I'll give you examples of movies I
wish we had created wholesale.
Um,
I wish impact theory had made the
matrix.
It's the perfect movie in my opinion.
I wish we'd made star wars.
The whole religion of the Jetta is
wildly empowering and think,
you know,
how ridiculous it is to say that you
wish you made the two greatest movies of
all time.
Of course you do.
Right?
But I'm saying from a guitar,
well actually I don't wish we'd made
avatar.
So,
um,
honestly I haven't looked at it closely
enough to know if it falls into that,
but I don't remember it having it.
That's more of like a,
a nature theme and taking care of the
current theme.
Whereas I'm looking for empowerment
themes.
So yeah,
empowerment themes in what?
Like in terms of fiction,
all of it is gone be documentaries,
like what are you going to try to do?
So mostly as of right now,
entirely fiction.
Um,
and the idea behind that is the way that
humans assimilate truly disruptive
information is through narrative and if
you've read Joseph Campbell's the power
of myth,
he talks a lot about that and the hero's
journey and so wanting to leverage that
and it's not an accident that I was so
impacted by the power of myth.
And then Joseph is the one that worked
with George Lucas on creating star wars
and making sure that real hardcore
mythology is at the core of it.
So I just think that's how we build our
belief system is how we build our
ideology.
It's how we pass it on to other people.
And I'm a big believer,
don't try to change behavior,
try to leverage it.
So people are already reading books,
reading comic books,
so on and so forth.
It's so weird a motivation to not just
make things that are entertaining but
the make things that are entertaining
that you think are going to be
inspiring.
But then to use star wars and the Matrix
is examples like,
do you think those movies really pulled
people out of anything or just entertain
people because I'd be much more inclined
to think the latter.
Sure.
So here's how I look at it.
I'm a filtering mechanism.
I can't save everybody and not everybody
cares.
So some people are going to respond,
some are the matrix changed my life in a
deep and fundamental way.
So I know the Matrix.
Yeah.
One hundred percent.
How so at the time when I had the fixed
mindset,
I'm literally right out of college.
I'm into depths of.
I'm not a talented filmmaker.
Now what the hell do I do?
Um,
I went to a comic con,
uh,
literally across the street from USC and
they were handing out tickets to go see
the matrix at Warner brothers studios.
And a very excited.
Took the ticket,
went that night,
went in.
Do you remember the movie?
Well?
Oh,
absolutely.
All right.
So when a agent Smith Goes,
no,
officer,
your men are already dead.
And then they cut to up their trinity
jumps,
camera,
go slow motion and spins around her.
The entire audience,
myself included,
yelled because it was just unlike
anything we'd ever seen in a movie.
It was such a rad experience.
And so that primed me for what ends up
being the perfect metaphor for limiting
beliefs.
And um,
you know,
Michael Strahan [inaudible].
Alright.
So Michael Strahan said the same thing.
He was like,
the year that he got the award for most
sacks in a single season was,
was because of the matrix,
literally his own words.
He came on an impact there.
I interviewed him asking that question.
He said,
without a doubt,
that movie is the reason that I got the
record because he said,
up until that moment I see morpheus and
neo training and Morphea says,
do you really think that,
um,
I'm faster than you because of my
muscles?
You really,
this is air.
You're breathing.
And straight hand realized,
Holy Shit,
I have a belief that I can only get one
sack per game,
but why can't I get too?
Why can't I get three?
And he said because of that he would get
a sack and then go,
no,
I can get another one.
And he said,
I realized in that moment that once I
got a second game I would back off
because I just believed that was like
the most anyone can do in a game.
So it had a similar impact me,
it made me realize I needed to figure
out what my,
what is the Matrix,
right?
I don't actually think we're in a
simulation.
So what is the Matrix belief system?
What is my version of jacking in
reading?
What is my Kung Fu business like?
Those were all the things that began to
sack.
It wasn't there while I'm sitting in the
movie theater,
but those were the things that were in
my mind and I just kept thinking about
it,
thinking about it,
thinking about it.
And I think in movies,
so when I give examples,
a lot of times I give examples from
movies because they have that impact.
Now,
the reason that I don't think something
like this would work,
and the reason that I think so many
people have not responded,
the way that I responded is nobody is
allowing people to take it seriously.
So social media I think is going to
change that.
So nobody's allowing people to take it
seriously.
Everybody brushes it off.
It's just entertainment.
So what do you mean by that?
So Joseph Campbell and the power of myth
talked about.
He was asked by Bill Moyer,
but Maria said,
I've seen it read it.
Okay?
So when he goes,
what do you think happens to a world
where people no longer believe in
mythology?
And Joseph Campbell said,
you're living through it right now.
And the point being that you have all
the mythology in the world,
but nobody believes in it anymore.
Everybody knows star wars in the real.
Everybody knows the matrix isn't real,
but people actually used to believe that
religion was real.
And so you had this mythological tale,
whether it was you know,
Zeus,
or whether it was Cassandra,
all the Greek mythology,
whether it was Jesus Christ didn't
matter.
People believed it.
They thought it was real and people
still do.
Correct,
but I would say that that's diminishing
day over day.
Um,
it's gotten less.
Will you give me that?
I'm from,
I'm sure ancient times.
I mean,
I don't know what the current state of
atheism,
agnosticism and deity worship is.
I would imagine it's probably somewhere
in the 50 percent range though.
I won't even challenge that.
I will give you my gut instinct.
My Gut instinct is while people are
still deeply religious,
they don't believe in the literal word
as much,
but let's,
um,
let's google like what percentage of
people today consider themselves
religious versus the past?
So if we get anything,
if get anything there,
we have people still cling to it because
it's a,
it's comforting and because the
uncertainty of existence and the finite
nature of our life,
it's a,
it's very disturbing.
That open ended feeling of not knowing
when it's gonna happen or what's going
to happen and having some sort of a calm
and peaceful belief in a,
an overlord.
Like someone was paying attention to
this whole thing.
It's got a plan.
I'll agree
to that.
My thesis isn't that people don't
believe in something,
it's that they don't believe in the
literal word as much as well.
Yeah.
How about this?
It didn't help me.
So there are some people out there are.
The numbers are there.
What do we get out of here?
Jeremy affiliated an affiliated rose
from 2007,
2014 by six point seven percent from
2014 from 2007 to seven years.
It rose by six percent identified
Christian on affiliated,
affiliated.
Nothing.
Any religion.
So there,
what?
Spiritual Christians went from 78 to 70
time period?
Seventy eight percent.
Wow.
I think it's American population.
The American population of Christians is
78 percent to 70 whatever it is.
So it dropped eight percent,
but still a giant number of people.
That's why you have to say you're a
believer in God in order to be
president.
They still maintain that.
That's like a,
a necessary thing.
Like if you are a person running for
president that says,
I don't know,
know,
I have no idea.
And I'm personally inclined to believe
that maybe,
uh,
maybe there's no god,
like people would go fucking crazy.
You would never get to be president.
We have this fundamental desire,
even if there's zero proof in there,
absolutely is zero proof,
especially when you think about the
stories in the Bible and some of the
more preposterous ones.
Um,
there's no proof that any of those ever
really took place,
isn't it?
I mean,
it's,
there's no proof that.
What was the guy that called,
called the she bear to kill the children
that were mocking him for being bald.
There was a no idea.
Don't know that story.
There was a guy in the Bible that,
uh,
these kids were giving them a hard time
for being bald.
So,
uh,
he,
he called upon God to avenge him and God
sent a bear to kill the children that
were mocking him.
Yeah,
that's intense.
That's what Eliza.
Uh,
yeah.
Alyssa,
how say that?
Alicia.
Yeah.
He went up to Bethel as he walked on the
road.
Some boys came from the city and mocked
him.
And,
uh,
when they mocked him,
God sent a bear.
And the bear fucking killed the kids.
Why?
Eh?
There's,
there's no guessing that didn't happen.
Kids.
I'm guessing that a Godson,
such a piece of shit that he has,
sends a bear to kill little children.
How about the kids?
Just,
they were talking shit about this guy
being bald.
I didn't know it was a bear with
sneaking up on them.
More likely to know when you're talking
about your shit,
you make noise.
The bears realize,
oh,
he's a high pitched noises,
probably delicious little kids.
And then they moved in but still 70
percent men.
So it's less people believe,
but still that's a giant number.
It is.
It is a giant number.
So yeah,
I mean that's a good question.
Like how many of them actually believe,
you know,
and what to what to what extent.
Right?
And what is it they actually believe.
Yeah.
So something,
uh,
my thesis is that something's wrong.
Uh,
this isn't uh,
an anti religion thing for me.
I have no beef with religion.
If it's making people positive and
connecting and doing something great,
I'm all for it.
I am not a religious person.
Um,
and so maybe I needed this for me to
have something that could give me the
ideology that I needed a reading.
The power of myth really changed my
life.
I read it and he talks about in the book
how I'm basically one of the things he
thinks is going wrong with divorce and
the reason that divorce rates are so
high is that ritual has really lost its
impact and you don't have these
demarcation points between childhood and
adulthood or between being single and
being married.
And he was like,
you know,
back in the day when you were 13,
they took you out of the woods.
They literally ripped you from the
clutches of the women,
took you out at with no anesthetic.
They would circumcise you and now you
know,
like you're a man.
So because there's none of that,
you get arrested adolescence and there's
sort of a weakening of the,
um,
the,
the import of the religious ceremony as
far as divorce goes.
And so people aren't taking that
seriously.
So.
And he talks about ritualistic scarf,
vacation and how many,
you knew something had changed.
When people put your body through some
kind of transformation.
So when I got married,
I went through a ritualistic
scarification to remind myself that I
was a different man the day before.
What kind of a ritualistic scarification
did you go through a tattoo?
A grandiose way.
But here,
how dare you call it?
Scarf.
Vacation.
That's how I saw it.
So I don't,
I don't do tattoos.
You'll see nothing.
I have one tattoo which I did
specifically for my wedding.
I've never gotten another one.
Um,
and at the time this isn't the case
anymore,
but at the time one of my biggest sort
of realistic fears was needles.
So it was me saying to my wife,
I'm going to go scar my body.
I'm using needles,
which freak me the fuck out to remind
myself,
hey,
I want it to be painful and then be.
I want it to be permanent.
And I'm glad that it's something that I
have this active fear of.
So in doing all of that,
it really did make the whole wedding
just a bigger deal to me.
And so that's really interesting.
But I think when we're talking about
Joseph Campbell and the,
the issues that I think are very real
about people not experiencing like a
grand event or at least some sort of a
ritual that gets them to adulthood.
Um,
I think there's,
this is a significant issue that we have
with just things being far too easy and
that there's no real difficult path
where the warrior has to find themselves
in,
you know,
in myth or in,
in a person's actual life that they have
to overcome some very difficult thing.
Now for you,
I'm sure some of those,
I mean we all have difficulties in life,
but some of the difficulties that you
experienced when you were in film school
was like this creation of this thing,
you know,
but once you try to create this thing
and it didn't work out,
right,
do you,
don't you have this desire to
go back and try to figure it out,
right?
Like,
don't you have to design like,
okay,
like I see where I fuck this up.
I try to be like John Wu instead of
trying to be like Alfred Hitchcock and I
see that there's like a way you could be
systematic.
You're obviously a systematic thinker
like you're talking about,
you're,
you're an organizer,
you have all these quotes in your mind
and you have all these systems that you
follow,
including,
like following,
like some of Gary vee social media
stuff,
right.
It's like your assistant.
You fall like these are ways to engage
in success.
Right?
So
I would feel like that would haunt you a
little bit.
It's interesting.
It doesn't.
So since then I have done,
I have done a low budget feature film.
Oh,
okay.
Um,
I wrote a screenplay that was turned
into a feature film that was a
horrifying experience.
Why was that?
Just because it didn't turn out the way
that I wanted it to.
It wasn't executed as written.
I mean,
look,
this is the age fighters complaint,
so,
um,
but I've,
I have changed as a person over time to
where I'm just now way more interested
in scale.
So I still have that love for cinema.
I love storytelling.
I think story is a,
it is a way that we assimilate
information like that is when I think
about the things that have painted a
vision for me of what is a man came way
more for movies and say my own father,
so and that that is not to downplay like
having a relationship with somebody that
you're in proximity with is,
is ultimately I think it'd be the most
powerful thing.
It's just not scalable.
So looking at how impactful media has
been for me and for a lot of people and
this whole notion of self signaling
because at the end of the day,
the way that I see the company is we're
a merchandise company,
so you create the intellectual property.
I mean this is a out of Disney's
playbook.
You create the intellectual property in
order to create the merchandise and this
and merchandise that drives a lot of the
revenue.
Not all of it,
but it drives a lot of the revenue and
in having that,
you also create this thing called self
signaling.
So as I dress a certain way to tell you
something,
which is how it starts,
it also tells me even more loudly than
you.
So as I like,
I have a Batman shirt and I have a
superman shirt and when I wear those
shirts,
it reminds me of my tie to that ethos,
right?
So Batman is.
You don't have any superpowers,
motherfucker.
You just have to work really,
really hard and you've got to be
prepared to tap into the dark side to
keep pushing hard enough to avenge what
you believe is your failing.
So Superman,
it's a perfect analogy for passion,
right?
He's a normal guy except when he's in
the Yellow Sun.
And that gave me a way to think about
getting in line with my passion.
I remember I was obsessed with that.
When I decided to go in and quit,
I was like,
I'm like Superman and I am out of the
Yellow Sun because I'm not passionate
about anything.
And the only time that I can do things
that make me feel that,
that are extraordinary or when I'm
really passionate,
the Matrix obviously is like the core
metaphor for my entire existence.
So what is such a crazy thing to.
Yeah.
So weird thing.
The Matrix is the wow,
the core metaphor,
right guys?
It's a metaphor,
but it's,
it's a core metaphor.
And not to be Joseph Campbell at that
didn't expect him to come out of my
mouth as many times in this interview,
but he said if you want to change the
world,
you have to change the metaphor.
So.
And people have talked a lot about that
with the,
how the world changed in the metaphor of
the steam engine to the metaphor of the
computer.
Uh,
and that just,
it changed the way that you thought
about workers that changed what you
thought about intelligence and just
changed a lot of things just by shifting
from one metaphor to the next.
Um,
so dealing in the realm of metaphor,
giving people access points to different
things through storytelling,
which obviously is riding on the back of
metaphor I think is an incredible access
point,
but more importantly,
it's something people already do.
So you're leveraging behavior that's
already there and that was like a
necessary part.
The same thing with quest,
right?
Don't ask people to eat less and
exercise more.
We've been telling them that for 60
years,
whatever it works for a narrow band of
the population,
but it doesn't work for everybody.
So finding something that people are
already doing,
people are already watching movies,
TV shows,
playing video games,
reading books,
comic books are already doing it.
They're billions and billions of dollar
industries.
Um,
so being able to tap into that leverage
social media now.
So this is where we first got onto this
part where I was saying,
you're in a position where most people
don't take it seriously.
They don't try to extract the life
lessons.
They're not Michael Strahan,
they don't see a movie one time,
but just didn't show it.
They just go to see a film to be
entertained.
This is a fascinating approach though,
to to create films,
to change the way human beings think
about life,
but now keep in mind if we don't
entertain first and foremost,
we've got nothing so people need to be
able to watch the movies and have no
idea that there's a message.
Disney is a perfect example of that.
Disney is trying to tell you that,
right?
Should always win bad.
They make movies for children.
Sure.
I mean it's,
it's a different thing like organizing
something like that.
A grand scale to make films for humans
that you think can pull them out of the
matrix through.
Do you think this works for kids,
but only kids.
I don't think kids are a little bit more
pliable and they don't have enough
information.
Sometimes you can show them,
show them some things through,
you know,
cartoons and things along those lines.
Set in with them a little bit easier and
better.
I mean,
it's absolutely possible to send a
message through a film that really
radiates with people,
resonates with people because I have a
deep and abiding fear that this is only
going to work with kids.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know that that's true,
but there's a guide,
you know,
Jeffrey Canada,
no,
super cool dude,
um,
grows up in Harlem and realizes,
do the school system is fucked.
Like everyone is just given up on all of
us here in Harlem,
but he's super bright.
Ends up going to Harvard and says,
I'm going to become a doctor.
I'm going to go back and change the
education system and does that.
Goes back and spends,
I don't know how many years in the
education system and just realizes,
yeah,
this never gonna work.
You can't change it from the inside.
There are so many.
Politics is so much entrenched.
Bullshit like this is going nowhere.
So he leaves and decides that he's going
to give up on adults and he's going to
start with kids.
In fact,
not even that he's going to try to find
women who are about to become pregnant
and all he wants to do is because he
looked at what makes a middle class kid
successful versus an inner city kid who
goes on to not be successful.
What's the difference?
And what he found was it's the number of
words that a child hears before the age
of five,
I think it is,
and the ratio of positive to negative.
He said,
your average kid in the middle class,
here's $5 million words for the time
that he's five 70 percent of positive,
30 percent of negative.
Whereas in the inner city kid,
here's like two or 3 million by the time
that they are five and the the ratio is
reversed.
So it's 30 percent positive,
70 percent negative.
So we said that's,
I'm just going to make my life's mission
solving that problem.
So that's an issue.
That's a gigantic issue.
Massive.
And he said what happens is the language
centers in the brain just don't develop
properly and because of that they
struggle later in life trying to get a
job because they can't communicate as
well.
Um,
so he felt like he had just put his
finger on sort of that baseline.
But the reason I bring Geoffrey Canada
up is because he gave up on adults.
So as I'm thinking through this,
look,
we haven't executed on this.
Nobody should be taking me seriously
right now.
I know that.
So I've got like this and I'm like,
everybody told us we were crazy when we
said we're launching a protein bar.
People like,
motherfucker,
you stupid.
1,600
protein bars in 2009.
It is the most crowded space ever.
One guy actually told us I need another
protein bar.
Like I needed another hole in the head.
And then five years later we're inc
502nd fastest growing company in North
America grew by 57,000
percent.
How?
Because we believed that it could be
done right.
So I get it.
People think you made a good product
also for enjoying it.
And that's what they wanted and that's
Kinda the same thing with making films,
like you have to make a good product
that people are going to enjoy,
but it's a fascinating thing that you're
coming to it saying that you want to
change people and take them out of the
Matrix because you're also saying that
your,
your like a memorabilia company or a
merchandise merchandise company.
I mean,
that's kind of the same thing,
right?
It's like you're,
you're,
you're talking like objects that go
along with your films.
And that's a big part of what.
So you're planning all this out from a
financial standpoint,
right?
But what about a creative standpoint?
Like continue to be able to put together
all these ideas,
like to say,
oh,
I want to make the new matrix.
Oh,
I want to make the new star wars and I
want to change the world on a drag
people out of this mundane reality they
live in and show them the power of myth,
right?
Yeah.
More.
I want to show them the power of belief.
I don't think they're ever going to see
the power of myth.
Why would they see it?
If you could see it?
Maybe they will.
I don't know,
just not a focus for me.
I just want them to take the usable
mindset and apply it and I think that we
live in an interesting time now where
social media can comment on the things
and say,
here's what's extractable from
so will you try to adjust films
accordingly?
If someone comes to you with an idea and
a script and they want this project to
be created,
you try to adjust it accordingly and to
try to have the highest amount of impact
and like how you going
do that?
Yeah.
So hopefully it will be a beacon to
people that really understand the
mindset.
So we laid out a three phase to building
the studio on the website literally from
day one and phase one is build the
community.
So we're building a community around
ideology.
People that come and listen.
In fact,
this is how you and I connected.
So one of my,
um,
one of the people that follows my show
wrote to you and said,
Joe,
you really got to get this guy in your
show.
And sent you a clip and you said,
hey,
this is actually pretty interesting.
You should come on.
Um,
so that's all around ideology,
right?
So I've spent the last 20 plus years of
my life constructing my mindset to allow
me to be successful and because I've had
a certain level of success,
people take me seriously.
So now what I'm trying to do is just
find the most efficacious way to
actually get that ideology in people's
hands.
And I know if I can incept them in
entertainment,
I've got a shot.
But if I can't entertain them first,
I've got nothing.
So if we don't have any way to sneak it
in,
if we don't have good movies,
like,
I mean,
I think this is where you were going to.
The movies aren't just good in and of
themselves.
Like we're fucked.
We've got nothing.
So we have to get really good at making
really good movies that people want to
see for their own sake.
So that.
And that's a Herculean task.
No question.
And we're going to have to assemble an
amazing creative team that really
understands that a very deep level,
the ideology of the company,
well in and of itself,
making entertaining films,
like having a company that makes
entertaining films with difficult,
brutal make entertaining films that have
this sort of life changing
message don't envy you.
That sounds like a long task.
But as like,
hey look,
it can be done if Disney did it.
And arguably they certainly did with
kids,
you know,
I mean they've,
they've made some really powerful movies
with some really good messages.
No question,
no question.
And look,
it's going to be a bumpy road.
I know that there's going to be sick.
Well the guaranteed failure and
hopefully success,
but it's something that I believe in
enough to fight for it.
So when you talk about,
you know,
um,
don't you want to go back and sort of
make good on the filmmaking promise?
No,
not,
not know what it meant.
What I meant was not,
there's no promise I just went,
does it something that you think like,
hmm,
maybe I could have adjusted.
Maybe I could have done this,
if it could have built on my skill set,
maybe I could have continued making
films and tried different approaches and
I feel like,
you know,
if you had a real passion for and it was
something that you were so interested
in,
you said you were killing it early on in
your film career or in your film school
career,
like a wonder why you didn't continue to
try to readjust and try to try to come
back as another.
Otherwise
that as well.
I think everyone,
myself included thought,
you know,
when we had this success equest and now
I can do whatever I wanted,
that I would just immediately start
writing and directing and it just didn't
feel it wasn't what I wanted to do it.
Yeah.
Well that's an important message in and
of itself because I tell people,
you know,
like,
look,
follow your heart's content and don't be
trapped in your earliest ideas.
If you have an idea early on that you
know,
I'm going to become this and then
somewhere along the line you discover
this new interest that kind of
supersedes the other one and surpasses
it.
Follow that one.
No,
you don't.
You don't have.
You don't have to.
Oh,
I thought you were a filmmaker.
I was a little.
Well,
you know,
like he can do whatever the fuck you
want.
I mean you could find a million
different pathways and a million
different avenues,
but ultimately what's going to resonate
the most with people,
something that you're actually
passionate about and really feel it
really feel not faking it.
Not trying to establish some sort of a
narrative that you think is going to be
successful with people resonate with
people,
but what do you actually feel and if you
could figure that out,
man.
No,
that's a.
That seems to be like the great pieces
of art.
The great works that people have created
that the opportunities that I've gotten
a chance to talk to people that have
done some pretty amazing shit.
It's all they.
It was all like an interest.
It was all a thought that they had that
they followed through all the way and
then got immersed in it,
you know,
but it was never thinking about it in
terms of the ultimate eventual result,
you know?
That's why I think it's interesting that
you're approaching this and you don't
just have an idea to make something
creative and,
and fascinating and fulfilling to enjoy,
but you also want to establish some sort
of a narrative that changes the way
people look at the reality around them.
Yeah,
definitely.
And when I,
when I think about what I'm really
driven by,
and this was almost a confession to my
team was I don't care about.
I love movies and I love the path that
we're on right now,
but I don't love it enough to risk my
fortune and to work as hard as I'm
working.
That just never would have drawn me
back.
So what I do care enough about to put
everything at risk and to work as hard
as I'm working is pulling people out of
the Matrix and I know those are my words
that maybe don't get people to see what
I mean.
So the kid that I big brothered for her,
just to give you an idea.
So his name is rashawn an amazing kid.
He was very disruptive in class.
He was drug and alcohol impacted but
still really bright,
but they had them on like Ritalin or
something.
I honestly don't know what,
but it's done to this gross groceries.
Really small,
hyper aggressive.
He was adopted and his mother was
abusing him,
but I didn't know that and very sad.
It was just too young and I just,
I didn't know what was going on.
Even though looking back you suddenly
realized,
Holy Hell,
there was so many clues.
Um,
but I didn't pick up on them and he just
living a life that is,
um,
is horrible and growing up in the inner
cities as well on top of all that.
And so I come and of course he's the
student they give me and all I'm
supposed to do is for eight weeks I'm
just supposed to come in and help him do
his homework.
And so he's very clever.
So I would show up and for an hour he
would ignore me.
He would get in fights,
he would push me away and then like five
minutes for,
I'd have to leave.
I'd say I have to leave and he would
start crying and freaking out,
please.
No,
just say help me with my homework.
And so finally I'd be like,
all right,
I'm going to help you,
but if you don't right now get to work.
I'm leaving.
And so then he would be an angel and do
his homework.
And then week two was exactly same and
three and four and five,
I thought this fucking kid is playing
me.
Like he's like trolling me in real life.
And at week six they tell you,
hey,
warn them that you're only coming two
more weeks so that they're not
surprised.
Cool.
Week six,
I tell them,
hey,
just so you know,
I'm only coming two more times and he
goes,
nuclear freaks the fuck out.
Like it was so shocking.
Like I didn't have experience with kids.
So he's flipping out and this was
already a kid with behavioral problems.
So I was just like,
the fuck is going on.
And finally,
slowly,
all too slowly I realized,
okay,
wait,
is this because I just told you I'm
leaving?
And he's like,
yes.
And I said,
look,
largely just to calm him down as long as
I live in Los Angeles,
I will help you do your homework,
but you have to do it the second I get
here,
deal.
And he said deal.
So that turns into an eight year
relationship where it became way more
than helping him with his homework.
I started taking him to movies and
trying to show them just a different
side of life.
And um,
took him on the saint called Troy camp.
So we got to see the mountains for the
first time and just all like really,
really getting involved in his life.
And then when his,
it finally came out that his stepmother
or his adoptive mother was beating him
from what I heard,
she was chasing him down the street with
a baseball bat and I just like,
I literally couldn't believe that was
real.
And so they took them away immediately
and I was the first phone call and his
lawyer called me and said he has asked
that you be the ward of the court or the
Guardian to help them through the court
system.
And so I helped them do that and help
them get into foster care.
And,
and I'm just looking at him going,
I know where this ends up,
like I know where this ends up and it
isn't good.
And so that was the seed,
right?
I didn't think that I'm going to
dedicate my life to helping people like
this wasn't that,
but it planted a seed and it really
fucked with me.
And I stayed involved with him in foster
care for a couple of years.
But then they just moved them so far
away that it was.
I was broke at the time.
It just was too far away.
So.
But that stayed with me and then when I
started,
um,
at quest and we were helping all these
kids are working with all these kids and
I saw how extraordinary they weren't,
which by the way drug dealers,
some of them are amazing entrepreneurs.
And so it became this notion of my,
it's unreal,
dude.
I'll tell you some stories sometimes.
Sure.
Absolutely fucking crazy.
And I thought,
Jesus,
you're a better entrepreneur than I am.
Like they're telling me how they watch
like the cop cars and when they change
shifts and how they know that they're
being identified by their cars.
And so they changed cars all the time as
crazy.
And so I'm like,
Jesus,
it gave me this concept that I called
mining for astronauts and I'm like in
here,
in here,
somewhere in here being the ghetto are
some of the most amazing minds I've ever
come across.
And these guys could be anything.
It can be fucking astronauts,
right?
Like whatever they wanted,
but they don't believe they can.
And when I would interview them it was
nuts.
So imagine you're interviewing.
And I came up with just like a fast
weighted where I didn't have to think I
could ask the same questions and one of
the questions was a magic genie shows
up.
It's going to grant you one wish and one
which only you can't wish for.
More wishes.
You can't cure cancer.
Bring anybody from back in the desk.
I'd be something for yourself.
What do you wish for universally to a
person?
They all said a job.
Okay,
that makes sense.
You think that's what I want to hear.
So you're trying to get a job so you can
tell him you want a job.
Then when we get past that bullshit,
and I tell you,
obviously that's not true.
Like what do you really want?
Like what's the job?
And to get you money.
Okay.
Do you want money or is it something
else?
No,
it's money.
Awesome man.
It's a magic genie can ask for whatever
you want.
What do you want?
You know what answer?
Every single one of them gave me
$1,000,000.
You can buy a fucking house for a
million dollars.
K,
it was so crazy.
It's a magic genie,
Joe,
like you can ask for a trillion dollars,
but their frame of reference is so
small.
One guy,
this was like the one exception said he
wanted an airport.
I found that so weird,
so I had to push on that one.
I was like,
why an airport?
He said,
because business guys come through the
airport,
and I was like,
okay,
what good does that do you?
And he said,
because then they can teach me about
business.
Nothing about that for a second.
How fucking many steps removed are you
from what you actually want?
But that's like they.
They don't have you say,
I'm a systematic thinker,
right?
So I had to learn that.
That's not where I started.
So I spent thankfully one of the things
I'm most grateful for in my life.
I have to learn everything the hard way,
but because I learned things the hard
way,
then I can show other people what I did,
where I fell down and how hopefully they
can avoid some of the mistakes.
Now,
most people ignore me.
I'm all aware of that,
but their desire to teach people that
this is what's interesting.
You're not just internalizing this,
this is not just yourself.
Correct.
And I,
look,
I'm wired for compassion.
I really enjoy other people succeeding.
Um,
the,
my favorite example of that is when I
was five,
so my sister would have been eight and a
half.
I pretended not to see some Easter eggs
so that she would win the Easter egg
hunt because she cared about winning and
I didn't.
So that's just a natural inclination
that I have,
that I've fed into that I've chosen to
take pride in.
Um,
and because of that,
and look,
it would be a way cooler story if I said
I met this kid rashawn and it changed my
life forever and I knew I had to
dedicate myself to helping people.
It didn't.
I met Rashawn and then spent almost a
decade chasing money.
Right?
That's the truth.
So,
but in that process,
like that way that I felt in those
moments where I had hoped that he would
do something when I met the kids,
that we're working on the production
line.
And I could see,
fuck I am.
One of them literally came to me is
absolutely hysterical.
He's in tears and he,
um,
he was like,
you're like my fa and stopped himself
and I thought obviously he was about to
say you like my father,
but that felt weird for him.
So he stopped and said,
do you like my older brother?
And he was like,
I've just never had anybody that
actually cared about me.
So now mix that with the fact that I'm
only interested in scale and maybe I
would be.
Does that mean doing touching 10 people
and like having 10 people show up at my
funeral and just be like,
this motherfucker changed my life.
And because of him like my 18 and all
that,
like they're going to have a better
life.
That just doesn't do it for me.
And I'm being honest.
Maybe maybe I am a worse person because
of this.
I honestly don't care.
It's just true to who I am.
So scale is interesting.
Having.
I would much rather touch a million
people and none of them know who I am
and know that a million people's lives
are better off than touched 10 and they
credited.
Ultimately,
it's just way more interesting to me at
scale.
Now.
I also believe that a five o one c,
three nonprofit is like the worst way in
the world to do something.
If you're trying to do good,
finding a way to do it through commerce
where it's a self sustaining economic
engine.
That's interesting because the thing
that like this is so weird to me.
If you have a nonprofit,
you have to go beg,
literally beg money from people that
have a for profit company that have
figured out how to make money.
They probably have a little bit of guilt
so they want to give money to you.
It is the weirdest dynamic ever.
Rather than just building a company that
at its core is trying to do something
good and awesome that you can be proud
of.
I'm fucking pr.
If I crash and burn,
I'll still be proud of what I was trying
to accomplish.
I believe in.
It makes me feel good to want to do
amazing shit for people.
I actually believe that this is the way
that you give somebody a belief system
that is antagonistic to acquiring a new
belief system because to do it at scale,
they can't want it.
Right?
The people,
the people that want to change their
physique,
do they eat right?
They exercise and they get results and
the people that don't and there are
people that I love very much in my life
and I'm going to lose them too early
because they don't want to eat better.
So the only solution I could think of
was there was no option.
Everything is healthy and delicious,
so all the things that you want to eat,
you can.
And so that was the mission at certainly
while I was there.
That was the mission of quest.
We're going to find one of those.
It was like 26 categories that we
thought got people into trouble and
we're going to make a healthy version of
each and every one of those
motherfuckers,
and that was the mission so that there
would literally be nowhere for people to
go to eat badly because they could just
pursue their most base instincts of just
gluttonous,
give me carbs,
sugar,
salt,
I want to all fat and that they'd be
eating a healthy version,
but it felt and tasted just like that.
So our first marketing message was stop
compromising.
So it.
That's a long way of saying it's all
about leveraging people's behavior
against them to get them to make the
right changes.
And I believe that the way that we're
going to do this,
we live in a unique time where I can go
and fucking microphones like this and I
can explain to people how to build a
mindset.
I do this literally.
I put out probably six or seven hours
worth of content every fucking week.
Well,
I'm just telling me,
yeah,
100 percent.
Really the day you're ready to come on
my show.
Be Raw,
which people have been begging for for
ever.
What's your show impact theory.
What does that.
So impact theory is me bringing on
people like you that have had just
unbelievable success and finding out
what are the things that you did to get
there.
So my interview style is,
I'll know more about you than your own
mother.
You'll show up,
you'll get a little unnerved because how
the fuck did I figure all this stuff
out?
But then we can have a really cool
interview because where ever you want to
go,
I'm going to be able to go.
I'm not a journalist.
I want you to shine.
Even if you have literally inspired me.
By the way I told you a little bit about
why when we first started talking.
Um,
I,
you're the only person that makes me
sweat from diversity cakes.
I fucked.
That's like my thing is an interviewer,
dude.
Like I can go,
I can interview anybody.
Doesn't matter.
But then I saw your fucking show and I
realized I can't interview a porn star.
Um,
I probably would suck with Hannibal
buress.
Somebody who's just fucking funny.
It needs somebody to go back and forth
with and I realized,
but fucking Joe can do dominic
d'agostino like on one day and then
immediately turn around and do like porn
joke anyway,
so would love to bring on people like
you come on because what it all started
back at quest,
I have this 25 point bullet belief
system that I wanted everyone in the
company to understand.
I used to be an employee.
I had an employee's mentality and here
are the 25 things I had to do to my mind
to become an entrepreneur and generate
wealth in my life and feel like I was in
control of my life.
Nobody else control my destiny,
but me,
here are the 25 things.
I had this unending fear that people are
going to memorize the fucking bullet
points and they wouldn't live them.
So I wanted to create a show where they.
Because it's hardest to impact those
closest to you don't know if you've
experienced that.
I certainly have.
So would say so.
Yeah.
So those that are closest to you,
why is it hardest?
I think it's because there's too much
familiarity.
My mom looks impact.
Do you mean in a way like inspired them?
Yeah,
right.
But not even through your own success.
You don't think that it inspires me.
Like my mom is finally starting to say
things like,
tell me a little bit more about
whatever,
but uh,
for a little bit.
But is that impacting her?
She just curious?
Not yet.
She's asking it in the way that like,
Hey,
I'm actually interested in making that
change,
but I'll just speak for myself in my
life for whatever inadequacy that I
have.
It's been very hard for me to impact
those closest to me.
So what I wanted to do at quest was
bringing in people that were wildly
successful and I want unprompted.
I wanted the audience to see.
You're going to hear them say the same
thing as I say,
even though we don't know each other and
time after time after time they heard
people going through.
These people have never seen the 25
bullet points,
but they would go through like,
I mean maybe it was like six or seven of
them.
It's not going to be exactly the same,
but they would touch on so many.
It was fucking freaky and so that really
started to play into,
okay,
we're now moving into a different era
where you can step forward and I think
transparency and authenticity are a big
fucking deal in,
in companies today.
I think that Gen z is going to demand it
and I think any company that hides Gen,
Gen z,
a z generation Z.
Yeah.
Have you not heard that?
No Man.
Welcome.
You're going to hear it everywhere now.
So is that the new lending that the kids
are saying?
New Kids coming up?
Generation z?
Yeah.
Oh,
if you type in Gen z,
you get like a bazillion sure results.
So Gen z ears are known for like they,
they say that they're the altruistic
generation so these people are not
comfortable with big business and I
think that they're going to demand a
level of transparency into the people
that are running the company and the
people that get that.
Elan Musk,
Richard Branson,
people that aren't afraid to like really
step out front.
Then people just resonate with that.
And so that is why I do all this.
That's why I'm stepping out front.
That's why I want people to know who I
am and what I'm doing.
I need to build a community if we're
going to pull off this mission
impossible,
uh,
building the studio,
that's all gotta happen.
So,
um,
that's why I create all this content.
That's why I bring people on that have
inspired me and my goal is just to set
them up.
So I want everyone to walk away from my
show going like off camera,
behind the scenes.
Like that was the best interview I've
ever done.
So,
um,
yeah,
that's,
that's like my mission.
I just want people to see it from all
these different angles here.
All these different people say it.
And quite frankly selfishly,
I want to learn.
And so one,
the biggest,
the thing that probably impacted my life
the most was when I stopped building my
ego around being smart and I started
building my ego around being a learner
and being super humble and sitting at
people's feet and just wanting to listen
and learn.
And then immediately put what I learned
into action.
So the show is also wildly selfish for
me and the staff because we get to meet
incredible people that have just super
empowering wisdom.
And so I believe that the dual track of
the social content was just on the nose,
right?
You would come on the show and you would
just tell us like how you did it.
You would talk about like how you got
into stand up comedy.
I got into stand up comedy because I was
a fucking funny guy when everybody else
was nervous.
Right?
But then like it actually has to become
a craft and you got to do it over and
over and over and talking about that
grind and how you get good over time and
people are going to trip the fuck out
and just like go,
whoa,
maybe that's exactly what I need to do.
Which is a message I think a lot of
people need right now,
which is,
it's a long grind.
So it's stuff like that.
But that's impacted.
Tom.
I gotta wrap this up,
but thank you very much man.
I appreciate it.
And good luck.
It's a very ambitious project and uh,
I'm certainly going to be watching.
Awesome,
man.
Thanks for me for stars quest.
I really love your bars.
You guys are awesome.
Thank you.
All right folks.
See you.
See you on Friday.
Bye.